the criminal trial of derek chovin
is still underway and if you're actually
following the trial watching the live
streams
you'd probably know it's not going that
well for the prosecution
if this is their case and they're
basically wrapping up at this point
and we're gonna move to the defense's
case i would say murder two is
absolutely out the window but we will
see
in the meantime riots erupted across
minneapolis yesterday
because of another police shooting and
this one is where things get
really interesting there's a guy who was
shot and killed
the female officer was pulled was trying
to plot a taser you can hear her say in
the body camera footage taser taser
taser
but she's holding her handgun she shot
him once one time he said holy s
i shot him now people are rioting
and a lot of people are looting so this
is where things start getting
complicated because the judge has
refused
to sequester the jury while one of the
jurors actually lives in this suburb
i i can't imagine it's going to be a
fair trial but we'll see how this turns
out and i think we really got to get
into
the merits of what happened with this
new shooting because minneapolis is a is
a is a is hot okay
you've got people who are ready to ride
who want to write and people who want to
exploit that and loot
and then this happens there's a lot to
go over in terms of justification
what'll happen with this cop is she
gonna be chauvin number two honestly i
think she might be
so we'll get into all that we got a
bunch of other fun stories we're gonna
talk about
the new disney plus show the marvel show
captain falcon and winter soldier
they're apparently doubling down on the
wokeness and everyone's making fun of
them so we'll get into that
and we got a really great guest we got
phil labonte of all that remains
hello what's going on man do you wanna
just quick little intro you've been here
before
uh i am phil labonte i sing for the
heavy metal band
all that remains uh we've been
a metal band for 20 years uh i am
uh active in the uh twitter sphere
i'm at phil that remains libertarian is
that uh
small l you know i mean like most people
most reasonable people
i don't i'm not a libertarian yeah i
guess um
so yeah come on man ian's chilling yeah
what's up everybody ian crawford over
here from ian crossland.net thanks for
coming and i'm in the corner pushing
buttons as i do
ladies and gentlemen before we get
started we actually have a new website i
can't believe it it's it's up
uh it's not perfect it's you know just
we're working towards getting
everything ready to go and we got to the
point where we're like okay we want to
do this two weeks ago
let's just put it up it improves a lot
of the bugs been happening before makes
everything prettier and more streamlined
go to timcast.com become a member
because it's not just about supporting
this show
it's not just about providing us that
security in the event we get banned from
youtube or any other platforms
if that happens you will find us at
timcast.com but it's about more than
that
we're talking with some comedians about
doing sitcoms we're already looking to
hire more editors news editor paranormal
we want to we want to make culture we
want to make fun exciting things we
actually just filmed a vlog
the other day with this pro bmx guy mike
feedy who actually finally grunted the
grind bar that's right
the bar we have in the garage it's not
completely built yet but he actually
he did a gap to feeble on his bike and
it was amazing
he almost tore down the whole the whole
pole barn which was also very cool we
filmed all of them and put that stuff up
that's what we want to do we want to
inspire people inspire young people
about
just being good people getting away from
this weird cultist
you know cult woke stuff doing normal
content speaking truth to power in the
real way that's we're gonna do today
so again go to tempest.com become a
member don't forget like share subscribe
hit that notification bell
let's jump into that first story this
one's got me hot
riled up i'm all angry check out the
story from intelligence or nymag
authorities say cop accidentally shot
and killed dante wright
this is an interesting story yesterday
we heard
that these cops shot and killed a guy he
got pulled over so his mom says because
he had air freshener hanging from his
his rear view mirror they say that's
illegal in minnesota
when his when he was pulled over the mom
says she heard on the phone he was
calling or trying to get the insurance
information the cops say get out of the
car
he says why and they say we'll tell you
when you get out of the car apparently
then
the mom you know gets off the phone he
puts the phone down body camera footage
finally gets released
it got released today i guess the cops
were very eager to put this out i guess
the cops
thought that by putting out this footage
it would calm things down in my opinion
no it's only going to make things worse
in the mind of these cops they're like
see
you have this lady cop and she's like
she else taser taser taser
you've got dante wright resisting on
camera trying to jump back in his car
and take off
and she's holding her gun she else taser
three times shoots him once and then
says
holy s i shot him he drove a little
a little bit crashed and then he died in
the car so the cops saying look we
genuinely believe
it was an accidental discharge that she
was trying to tase him
there's a lot of issues here first and
foremost black lives matter protests and
riots erupted immediately
then many of these people who had been
seen at these rallies started looting
stores i
got these people hit me up on twitter
and they're like how do you even know
those people are black lives matter
there's like a photo going around of
them literally waving a black lives
matter flag i'm like come on dude
i'm not i'm not trying to besmirch the
good name of literally everybody who
believes in justice i'm pointing out
these people are protesting one minute
some of them go off in loot it just
happens
some losers exploit the whole system now
all's is happening in the backdrop of
the chauvin trial so things are going to
get absolutely nuts
summer is lighting up and there's a meme
going around where it says
how to tell it was summer 1990s it's the
guy holding up punk's tiny phil or
whatever that
groundhog's name is and says to 2020 and
it shows a dude sending out a car with
his fist stop and there's fires all
around him yeah that's right
we know that it's getting warm outside
because the riots are going to start
and if these cops think that any one of
these extremists that are going around
burning on the city are going to give
them an inch
they're insane i think this lady cop is
going to go to jail they're going to try
and charge whatever they can they might
even get
get her on murder 3. we'll break all
that down but you know before
before i go nuts and just rant all that
stuff i want to just throw it to you
guys
like your thoughts immediately on on the
news coming out of these rides and stuff
uh well i mean you mentioned um
that she had an accidental discharge and
that was purely negligence um
she didn't know what she was doing
um the police frequently need more
training
yeah she panicked um you know you hear
stories about
you know police looking for or they're
they're talking about uh
defund the police and honestly police
probably need more funding for training
that's what i've always been saying yeah
i mean if if if you are
given the power over life and death of
of citizens if you are going to be
given a firearm to go out in the
community and stuff
you want your police officers to have as
much training as possible
you probably should roll back
legislation because you don't want
police doing
all the jobs that they're supposed to do
i understand that being a police officer
is hard i'm not like a
you know an a-cap dude at all um and
it's a difficult job
but that doesn't mean that we have to
make uh make exceptions for when they
make mistakes you have to be held to
account when you make a mistake and that
negligence cost a man his life
for nothing because he was like
we talked earlier he the reason that he
had a so we're gonna get the full layers
of this thing right now you're gonna go
right for it
i mean you know i'm a big 2a guy so you
know
the the the reason that he had a warrant
was because he was carrying a gun
in violation of state law but in my
opinion there shouldn't be a state law
regarding carrying a gun i agree so this
is a sandwich here we got we got
a we got a libertarian he shouldn't have
resisted libertarian argument right the
way i see it is
here's what happens with this guy he
gets pulled over he didn't realize he
had a warrant
andy no put up his the the record of
what the award was all about
here's what i think happened they say he
was in possession of a firearm without a
permit
and he fled by means other than a
vehicle both misdemeanors
i think this guy got stopped at one
point and he had a ruger 45
and the cops saw the gun and said you're
under arrest and he ran and got away
i bet he thought he was clean he got
away the cops got a warrant for his
arrest
so when he gets pulled over he's
thinking like it's no big deal then when
they're like
get out of the car and he's like what's
going on you're under arrest then he's
like i gotta i gotta flee i gotta get
out of here
he shouldn't have resisted arrest if he
didn't listen so like
i guess where we're going with this is
he shouldn't have received any warrant
or charges simply because he had a gun
but if he didn't resist and he just put
his hands behind his back on two
misdemeanors
then a gun rights group or someone could
have advocated for his right to bear
arms
yeah you know you never you never should
resist because
it always ends with more it always
escalates to more force
well i never say never but 99 points
almost yeah it's your chances of getting
shot
go up exponentially as soon as you
resist so
fight the fight in the court you don't
fight the police you're going to lose
and there's always more cops there are
always more cops coming
there's backup coming and there's backup
to backup i mean it's like
it's like like gta eventually the
national guard with tanks come
if you kill enough cops in the game
right so eventually
they're gonna come with like the apc's
you are gonna get
shot killed don't fight the cops fight
in court
that being said you shouldn't have to
have so many interactions with the
police you shouldn't have to worry about
i had a gun and the police are gonna
take me to jail for it
you know just for possession possessing
a gun so i say
when i say never say never about
resisting i'm not talking about you know
cop says look you got a warrant you're
under arrest
i i the reason i say that is because
like there might be a cop committing a
crime legit sure and he's like i'm a cop
i can do what i want okay that's
different you know i mean that's why i
say never say never
if you get stopped by companies like
look i'm arresting you you're not going
to win
if you're if you're trying to get a
physical fight the smart people you know
you keep your mouth shut
you just remain silent put your hands
behind your back you get you call a
lawyer as soon as you can
and uh you gotta fight in the system
it's not it's not easy
the right to remain silent is a right
that is an option
and it's also your absolute best option
if you feel that
you're in a position where you know
where the police are
doing something wrong explain you know
say look i don't consent to any searches
here's my information and then you don't
have to say anything else if you don't
want they're gonna say that you're being
uncooperative they're gonna say
things to try and intimidate you they're
gonna say things to try and make
their own job easier because that's what
it boils down to is they want their job
to be easy
because most of them look at it as it's
just a job i'm doing my job this is you
know you don't make my job harder
but you still aren't obligated to talk
to the police just don't say anything
but don't resist now we go to the next
layer of this whole thing
the rioting is the worst part about all
of it like well the dead guy's the worst
part about all of then the second worst
right absolutely absolutely i mean like
you know moving beyond that sure that's
why i should clarify too
you know after this instance we have a
bunch of people going around riding
destroying everything
and for what for wha why why why are
they going to mobile and getting stopped
and stealing twerking in the parking lot
as they do it it's not for justice
no it's not but is is the media going to
come out and be like opportunist looters
are destroying the city
no because clicks yep
i mean if the more the more
intense the situation gets on the ground
the more people are going to click the
headlines
the more profit the media will make this
is this is weird to me though like
you'd think the shock content of like
rioters burn down
the city would be the narrative that
would generate the most tricks for like
uh clicks for like a suburban family
they should be writing headlines
that are like you know crazy riders are
burning down the city how long until
they come to your house
instead they're like peaceful protesters
are shopping without permission
at night i got nothing i don't know
i don't know what they're thinking i i
agree with you um
the stories themselves i feel like are
enough to get people to click
i think that the the narrative that's
being spun
um by most of your major media outlets
is uh is what they believe people want
to read
so like you said you know side with the
audience and i think
that's what people really want you said
that you searched riot
on google search we'll jump to that
that's crazy but
i want to i want to get back on the gun
thing because like the one thing that's
really pissed me off
i tweeted this woman should be this lady
cop send her to jail lock her up yeah
and it was funny because all these
lefties were like based tim
like is tim like hold on hold on there's
two things i want to say here
i i've bought a bunch of guns recently
and every time i go there
there's one very important thing that
every gun owner has told me no matter
what happens
you are responsible for what comes out
of them accident or otherwise
you can take responsibility that's why
it is your responsibility to
have all of the basic training don't
point the gun at something unless you
intend to destroy
it keep your finger off the trigger guns
are always loaded all of these rules
now i get it this lady she screwed up
she thought she was going for a taser
she yelled taser but she was holding her
gun heated at the moment she was
panicked people don't realize that
stress
she's still responsible for what comes
out of that absolutely absolutely now
here's the other thing though
because we were getting into this i'm
i'm extremely pissed
about this whole interaction i don't
blame the cops themselves for being like
he's gotta want we gotta arrest him
because they don't necessarily know what
this is all about but
like we mentioned this guy had a fort he
had a gun
and that was the grounds for him being
charged with the crime
what what what law did he break the
constitution says shall not be infringed
he didn't rob anybody
and i'll tell you what really bugs me as
i'm seeing conservatives post this guy
there's one viral twitter post where
he's like this guy would have robbed you
in two seconds cause
he's got photos of him pointing a gun
i'm like nah nah you have a right to
bear arms sorry
absolute garbage take the idea that that
that someone can
predict that that oh this guy would have
done this or would have done that
there is absolutely no way of knowing it
and
just because the conservative doesn't
like the way the guy looks
doesn't mean that the guy doesn't have
rights he has rights
for sure i do think that's like photos
of him with like his gun and he's like
pointing it at the camera
and i'm like that's cringy i mean it's
cringy but i
i know that there are pictures of me
holding guns out there you know i mean
i'm a big
2a guy i've gone and i've got videos on
my youtube page that of me at
classes training you know which if you
i'm going to take one second and steal
the spotlight here if you own guns get
training
please please get training that's it's
the best thing
the most responsible thing you can do is
know how to properly
use your gun all right so you were
saying before the show you took a police
training
gun class oh yeah that's totally
inadequate uh absolutely yeah
i so i've done uh first first time i
ever shot i went to a range with some
other gun people well i should say with
one guy who was like
well versed in guns for a variety of
reasons he's a conflict reporter and
he's been in countries where they have
full auto just rampaging about
so that's where he gave me some basic
instruction i wouldn't say it was like a
legit training but i actually did do an
interview with a police trainer and went
and went through the full police
training it's like a day
it's one day so i'm like sitting in a
classroom they're going over all this
basic stuff they're talking about
you know a good shooter bad [ __ ] things
like that and then they allowed us to
sit in on it and then afterwards we went
to their range
and they walked me through the use of
like all these different guns down from
like starting with like a 22
handgun like really easy for someone
who's never shot before even though i
had and then
up to i can't remember what the highest
caliber they were they had was you said
what do you think it was like a 10
millimeter could have been 10 mm it was
it felt like it was bigger than 45 or
something something magnum probably
and uh so i shot all these different
guns and the reason i say was inadequate
so i'm like
dude i shot like 12 bullets you know
what i mean and
my aim is not good with these things i
was missing everything now long guns a
lot easier
to be accurate with but i'm imagining
like a lot of these people who went
through this were doing it to get some
kind of certification
and then you put these people out on the
street so so certification is not enough
the big reason to go for training i mean
just
a certification is basic understanding
and stuff the reason you should go for
training is
is so that way you know how to operate
the gun should you need to
you learn things like clearing your
garment if you're carrying it concealed
things that are practical and and
how to draw your gun and keep your
finger off the trigger while you're
drawing it because one of the things
that happens too frequently is people
grab their gun
and their hand goes right into the you
know their finger goes right into the
trigger guard when they're pulling it
out and they they have a negligent
discharge and
stuff this is something we were talking
about just before the show i'm like what
she had a glock
i'm pretty sure there's a glock and then
we have safeties and i'm like i wonder
if this whole thing would just be
be solved if they gave her like a
beretta with like an actual safety on it
just
click the whole safety up those things
are like like we said those are training
issues where
right if you have a firearm with a
safety on it
again if you train pulling a firearm
with a safety and and
turning the safety off it doesn't make
it it doesn't take any more time
you know you don't have a you're not a
slower you know it's not slower to get
the gun out and stuff
um but it's a training issue if you have
a gun like that you need to train with
it
training is one of the most most
important aspect aspects of owning she's
going to be chauvin number two
probably you should you should go to
training every year i'm going this
weekend you should go to
one training class a year i can't drive
that point would you argue that the dude
got in his car and don't looked like he
was diving for a gun
yeah a lot of people i mean that's fair
probably what she thought he had a gun
no no
no no no no no she was going for a taser
she said she said she thought he was
going for a weapon
so that's why she said taser taser taser
i think it's definitive
like a reasonable person would conclude
she thought she was grabbing her taser
not her gun
but it is fair to conclude they thought
he may be going for a weapon because he
had
his warrant was for having a weapon i
just i don't care for that argument
everybody should have a weapon because
the constitution says you can and if you
want to change it
you you change constitution yeah but not
everyone should die for their weapon
when they're being detained nobody
should die for their weapon at all
zero people exactly there should be oh
people diving for their weapon
when they're getting arrested by the
police cops pulling you over you're
getting arrested you keep your hands
visible
you obey you put your hands behind your
back you let them cough you you keep
your mouth shut
you deal with it through the courts what
people don't realize when all these
people resist arrest and they're like
this is bs man you can't arrest me dude
this is the good
side of things in some countries they
just beat you to death right there on
the spot
in some countries they just put a cap
and then they're done in america
oh no you have to go and have a lawyer
represent you
and you get to actually come out and
bond someplace they're doing cashless
literally first world problems yeah as
much of a hassle as it is you're totally
right you're
100 on the money there it is first world
problems that you have to go to court
and go through a justice system as
opposed to getting your
ass handed to you or just being locked
up throws away the key
it's it's amazing that that we're so
used to this amazing system that the
founding fathers had to die
for yeah what is it you might know this
better than me where it's like a certain
number of those of the men who signed
the declaration of independence
lost their fortunes were killed their
houses were burned to the ground
yeah that's what they fought for to
ensure that when we get arrested
we get to go to court they pledge their
lives their fortunes and their sacred
honor
yeah you know and and many of them died
and
like didn't have anything left to their
kids their houses were burned their
families were killed
um we know about a lot of the founding
fathers that survived and stuff but
there were people that signed the
declaration that lost everything yeah
you know and died for it
and and part of that what they got us
was the bill of rights which is the
right to a speedy trial
right that's that's the fifth i think
right it is in the fifth year quite
literally the right to a trial is that
you're going to get arrested you're
going to go before a judge and you can
ask for a jury of your peers
it's not easy and it's not always fair i
think you know it's better than
uh you know 10 guilty persons escaped
than one innocent person absolutely
but we strive for that it's not easy and
there isn't justice but it's like dude
you're getting arrested
i'd be like man i'm sure glad i'm not in
turkey yeah really or in chile
yeah i like how you phrase it you get to
go to court because in a lot of yeah
if you're lucky to go to court you just
get beat down or bro if you don't bribe
them then
you suffer yeah in turkey if you're a
journalist they just lock you up and you
don't get out
yeah that's just going to jail and then
the saudis come and kill you
they're in the embassy so turkey has the
worst
laws for journalism and so i've been
there reporting a couple times
and the the pro-turkey people try to
justify it's like no no you don't
understand you don't understand
turkey is really good for journalists
the people who are arrested
aren't journalists they're like
activists claiming their journalists
because they have a cell phone and i'm
like
so journalists like sorry dude i i get
it i got your songs so we see these
people out
it's one thing if someone's like i'm a
journalist and they throw a molotov
cocktail it's another thing when there's
a guy wearing an antifa sticker is just
filming yeah push that guy aside he's
allowed to film it's an active
journalism
but in turkey they don't care they lock
you up they throw away the key you don't
get a first amendment you don't get a
fifth amendment you don't get a second
amendment you don't even have the first
amendment in
in countries that allegedly have the
freedom of speech in britain
in the uk you can get thrown in jail for
for bad facebook posts in canada you can
get thrown in jail for
saying the wrong thing in the uk you
could do something like i don't know
teach your pug to do like the roman
salute or something for instance and for
instance yeah yeah and then they'll lock
you up and
and then mark yeah then you can teach
your other pog who's actually a black
pug
to do the black power fist and they
don't care at all
yeah that i got i got to say for those
that aren't familiar i'm making a
reference to count ankula
when he did his first video which got
him in trouble was
he he wanted to make his dog a nazi his
girlfriend's dog because it was you know
uh the nastiest thing he could think of
but he later on after all of this he's
been through he made a video where the
other pug who was black he had it raised
its fist for black power
and it's hilarious and i got i got to
admit the cajon is on this guy
going through the courts they seize they
try to lock him in jail he's laughing
the media smears him
and then he's like i'll do it again but
you know what he knew he knew
they wouldn't arrest him for the black
power thing that was the point and the
video is really good
he's like oh no the labor party's coming
as i hide the torah
i hope he moves to the u.s
i feel for people when they see like
american comedy and they try and pull it
off in their own country and get busted
by their
their cheap law enforcement well let
let's talk about uh i'll talk about the
media because you mentioned this a
moment ago ian check this out
when you google search riots right now
my friends those those of you who are
not watching just listening
we know that riots erupted in
minneapolis we know that people are
scared the jurors are scared
that if they give i think this was
expressed in the trial during this
election
that if they say not guilty for chauvin
it's going to the city's going to burn
to the ground
what you need to understand is it's not
just about whether or not chauvin gets
freed or goes to prison there's three
charges
chauvin can be acquitted on one two or
three
or none and that means out of all the
potential scenarios and everything we've
seen
i would be willing to bet you will get a
headline that says derrick chauvin
acquitted
in the murder of george floyd and then
it'll say
he was convicted on this on third degree
murder and manslaughter but acquitted in
second degree and they use the most
shocking headline acquitted in the
murder of
because they want you to freak out with
that
the media knows exactly what they're
doing and i can prove it
by simply go and and google i gotta say
whatever their system is whether it's
intentional not it's totally in on it
right now there's riots happening in
minneapolis and guess what story you get
when you go to google and you type in
the word
riots there it is the first result out
of 17 million
nine hours ago the washington post
headline data about the capital rioters
serves another blow to the white working
class trump supporter narrative
what this was
three months ago they need the milk
i mean we just had riots the other day
yeah i mean there's been riot there's
been riots going on in portland
for a year a year like every night i
know that i've seen
stuff about it in the past month and
they're still talking about the capital
right
because because because the orange man
is very
bad ian don't you know
your point is made the orange man he's
very bad
and people cannot forget that he is a
very bad
orange man how is it that google
17 million results the top post it's
dated about the cap and then underneath
it
people also searched for riots of
minnesota why would they search for that
could you imagine being in minnesota and
being like you're hearing bangs and
screaming and you're like what's
happening so you go on google and type
in it's like
capital rights you go i don't care about
that it's ridiculous that you have to
specify
in it it is ridiculous that you have to
specify
what riots when it comes to a news
like which ones which is the ones that
have been going on in portland
is it the one that happened at the
capitol is it the one that's happening i
mean
that's that's it's ridiculous hold on
you ready for the best part sure i'm not
done give it to me i'm not done give it
to me
the first post when you search for riots
it's not black lives matter it's capital
riots
then you have people also searched for
newsweek dw and national review
talking about minnesota but these aren't
the results for riots these are people
also searched for riot in minnesota
google is letting us know these three
results are suggestions
not based on the search term riots and
guess what the actual
second listing is in the search term
riots
right now as we literally had riots
yesterday
well the first one was the capital and
the second one is from cnn one hour ago
trump state department appointee facing
capital riot charges
released from jail what's the third
clear the capital pence pleaded
what's the fourth you're going to die
tonight body cam footage shows
forget and then and then and then and
then number five
tmz dante write oh not news
tmz got it right tmz it is the fifth
result right now a day after the city
was being ransacked and looted and
there's tear gas and fires
they're still talking about the capital
three months ago i suppose that it
is fair to point out that this speaks to
your
a point that you've made multiple times
about the
media loving donald trump and losing
that
the the revenue that he generated for
them
yeah um because nothing nothing in
in the past 10 years has gotten clicks
like
you know the orange man being very just
why aren't they
cognizant of this fact where they can
just say well we have to move on
you know so like what am i talking about
on my main channel tim cast
last year i'm like democrats republicans
election election laws what's happening
all very election related i get people
going like all you do is talk about
politics no you just talk about cultural
issues i'm like dude what do you
what's the big thing going on right now
now we're outside of the election and
what am i talking
about chauvin trial i've got like four
out of the past five videos about the
chauvin trial because this is the big
impact it's where the news is going it's
what's important i'm not talking about
trump trump trump used to be
seriously in like my my tags first word
because like it was always
it was always trump it was always
something with trump and even i was like
jeez you know i'm tired you know this
guy's suck up the air
now we're in a new space there's news
happening people want to know what's
happening and what do you think about it
so
for people come to me they're like tim
tell me what you think about this
because most people
already know what's going on you've seen
the news article yourself
you talk to your friends about it you go
online to find commentary to maybe think
of something or hear something you
didn't think of yourself i do this
right so now people are going and
they're going to google and type in
riots what's happening enter the fifth
search result
was tmz and it was the first talking
about
dante wright do you know what the sixth
is
capital rider xlypd cop stunned he's
being held with inner city criminals new
york post
it's not just the left the new york post
is a is a conservative
conservative outlet they're the ones
that broke the hunter biden laptop story
even then 11 hours ago amazing
and you know it's really funny the next
next one is about kenosha
it's remarkable to me that if you search
for riots you are not getting served
information about what happened in
minnesota
and it's primarily because many of the
big mainstream news sources that
dominate search results
ain't talking about do you crosscheck
duckduckgo do you search with duckduckgo
over
no no i usually don't even use google to
find stories i you know go through
various news sources and i use twitter
and i kind of curate can't get it up on
my phone i'm interested to see if you
search right on duckduckgo
that's a good point that's a good point
let me see if why can't you get it up on
your phone i don't know how to switch it
in my uh in my brave browser
on the fly i'll check into it though
all right maybe goes i'm not saying i'm
not blaming google necessarily right
uh so the first result is recent news
massive rise in minnesota minnesota
riots
clear the capital so the first two in
recent news
on uh go is minnesota
so it could be always then we get uh
general riot not even news so after
that's like definition of riot
not even news but let me click news to
make sure i'm being absolutely fair
right games
number one when you go to riots all
duck.go massive rides in minnesota click
the news tab
the first result massive minnesota riots
massive rights in minnesota
the second one several minnesota
businesses looted the third cleared the
capital
so they still have some of these stories
but duckduckgo is prioritizing better in
my opinion
could be the google algorithm is just
tainted towards
trash bait you know flashbait or
whatever or it could be that larry and
sergey
are political i mean those guys run
alphabet they're basically the owners of
alphabet it's the it's the trash bait um
we know that google has a news source
ranking
where they like i think a bunch of
conservative
outlets don't appear in search
particularly bright brown i think
breitbart's like omitted
and we've i think we saw this leaked
actually i think looks like veritas or
somebody leaked where it's like here's
the google blacklist
of all the websites they don't allow to
appear in search or are limited
for a while even my youtube channels
were and then it wasn't until on this
show i said hey my youtube channel is
our blacklist they removed it so i'm
like google must be listening
they're listening but that's this is
what's happening google
you and i think it is i think it's like
a toilet being flushed and like all the
turds are being swirled towards the
middle
so what happens is google i believe
genuinely
and from their own bias i'm not saying
they're i'm not saying they're not doing
things wrong i think
they think they're genuinely doing the
right thing they're like we gotta get
rid of this fake news let's make sure we
only prop up you know cnn
washington post msnbc cbs abc nbc etc
new york times
those outlets are then suffering their
ratings are collapsing their
subscriptions are down so they're like
just make trump trump trump trump trump
so when
we're three months out from from the
capital riots or protests or
insurrection we're gonna call it
they're still doing it because here's
what happens
like many of the grifters the people who
are all about just pandering to the
tribe
the news outlets built up an audience of
angry establishment democrats and
leftists if they come out now
and say something they're worried they
will lose money so they're like they're
they're probably sitting there i've been
in these editorial meetings i imagine
they all sit down and they're at the
table and there's someone on the phone
some editor or some boss
like okay so what are the stories that
we got and they're like well we had
those riots yesterday in minnesota and
they're like
well you know um we haven't got a
resolution yet why don't we hold off on
that one
we can talk about the capital you know
some of these guys are getting arrested
capitals great let's talk about the
capital
and what what you don't hear in the
actual words which what underlines this
is the boss going if we talk about
the minnesota stuff we're going to piss
off a lot of our subscribers and lose
money
capital now that's that's that's money
and that's safer for us
let's go with that one yeah i mean that
seems like a reasonable take
um especially considering um a lot of
the
the more progressive news
outlets are run by people that are
not as interested in progressive uh
issues as they are in the bottom line
you know
when siding with your uh siding with
your
audience is the primary driver
you know you don't want to you don't
want to focus on things that will
upset them or or drive them away do you
think they they were like well there
were riots so let's
write a story with that flash word in it
and then so they they said okay we got
to write a story about riots because
riots are popular right now there's
going to be a lot of riot search results
so then they pick the the most trashiest
riot and they're like let's write about
the
january 6 or is it just i've been
writing about that crap anyway
i hadn't thought about that but maybe
they do um
i i would i think that i would look
uh in the next couple days to see what
happens
if that if if there are a lot if there
continue to be because
they didn't know that they were going to
be riots today two days ago and some of
the stuff that tim was pulling up was
from
you know uh you know yesterday or the
day before whatever the riots are
have started off today i believe so or
at least the ones in minnesota because
of the uh
the cops bad shoe would you like to play
a game
yes why would you like to play a game
click here so i pulled up two
progressive sources
okay it's not this is not science this
is just me pulling up two progressive
sources
then msc msnbc and fox news to see what
they're talking about
and it's exactly as i thought first we
have slate.com
what's their headline story inflation is
about to look freaky
slate.com is a leftist publication you
think they'd be talking about something
we got over here a small
little you know blurb on the left is
derek chopin's defense flailing
the answer to that question is no by the
way but uh the the big story isn't about
minnesota in fact i don't even think i
see anything on minnesota all right okay
well slate's of the biggest
let's try vox vox vox.com okay let's
jump over to vox and what do we see
for the main number one story the
hottest number in conservation is rooted
more in politics than science
why the u.s egg industry the christian
right the chauvin trial feels momentous
georgia companies banding together
natural born citizens biden's plan the
bizarre push where's the minnesota riots
okay okay okay hold on now fox news now
we know fox news is going to be talking
about the riots
rupert murdoch all right pull up fox
news the top story is
city manager fired for demanding due
process for cop in deadly shooting
mayor takes control of police okay so we
got dante wright from fox news
it's actually i don't i wouldn't say
it's right biased
but they're just saying the cop demands
due process and got fired that's
fairly neutral but they are talking
about it they're not talking about in a
positive light right
i mean sort of the consequences well no
it's just that nowadays the constitution
is a right-leaning uh issue it's not
like okay the left doesn't give a crap
about the constitution
all right well just below this on the
front page of fox news
bracing for violence live updates
curfews and effect across minnesota
crowds swarm
nyc streets all right well the two
progressive sources weren't talking
about it at all
fox news is now what do you think msnbc
has to say
uh nothing good and msnbc top story
yamachi yamashi alicendor dante writes
shooting as a recurring nightmare for
black americans
it's exactly what i thought it was going
to be i thought the progressive
outlets would probably blurb this
somewhere but not really talk about it
and the big networks were going to
choose their position
fox news this is bad prepare for
violence msnbc it's a nightmare what's
happening
not referencing the nightmare for
everybody else as their city burns
so you know what i like to say why not
you know
i guess one thing i can give credit to
what we do here
i tweeted the cop should be in jail like
like i already said whatever comes out
of that gun that's your responsibility
i'm not saying murder charges because i
don't think that's not going to stick
there was no intent but she screwed up
and i had a bunch of lefties saying your
followers sure are gonna hate this one
tim and i'm like well i don't care like
people don't know
people that aren't aren't involved in
the the gun world at all they don't know
how people that are involved in the gun
world think
um right good
good i was going to say conservatives i
think who are more concerned about black
lives matter and rioting
are are going to be less pro-2a
libertarians who are very very staunchly
pro-2a a not big ella returning just
libertarian in general
are going to look at this and be much
more about gun rights yeah if you're pro
2a
especially if you're a young younger
person that's pro 2a
the idea of of being exclusionary when
it comes to your
pro second amendment uh attitude that is
that is old person stuff
that is that is that is fud talk you
know like seriously that is that is
that is not what you see
when you talk to people that are pro 2a
nowadays you're saying they want it
across the board it's it's a very
inclusive
inclusive thing you've got people like
mashter and you've got people like
colian noir out there
uh you know really representing uh you
know
representing black people that that have
just as much love for
the the gun world as uh as anyone else
or
as any white people do so if you if you
tell me
that this dude you know in in
dante wright was a violent criminal who
should be in prison and all that stuff
i'm like i don't think you're actually
pro too i think you're just a tribalist
if you say look man he shouldn't have
resisted arrest the cop i understand
what happened i agree
you're right however he should be
allowed to have his gun yeah it
shouldn't have been an issue in the
first place
so but here so we'll and we'll we'll
just reiterate this point
because for this segment dante wright
should have just been arrested he should
have put his hands behind his back
and then someone could have advocated
for him yeah because then they would
have been like is the only thing he's
being charged with is that he was
carrying a gun
i'm pretty sure the second amendment
says the right to keep and bear arms
will not be infringed
what is his crime and then you sue he
would have had standing to make a
challenge maybe at the supreme court
and then it would have been exonerated
it would have made the whole country
better for everybody should never
resisted
he shouldn't have been criminalized in
the first place for his right to bear
arms
so it's a layered thing it is but uh you
know long story short
that's what we get from the media but we
do have more riots so um
don't worry the riots don't end oh they
don't don't worry guys
this is more riots more rights riots
rock montreal
covet 19 lockdown protests turn ugly
okay i mean i don't blame them
considering how
the uh the the country the the federal
government up in in canada has been
behaving uh
but it is i mean it is fairly impolite
to riots i'm a little surprised
they're very polite up there yeah i
think uh i disagree with the rights i i
think the lockdowns at this
point are are proving to be have been
mistakes
uh we should have done i think what they
call the surgical strike where it's like
protect the elderly protect the
vulnerable and then have
like limited restrictions yep now you
got
the today show they were they were on
the segment that goes viral where
they're like
texas and florida see their covid cases
going down
below the national average whereas
stricter states like new york and
california see their cases rising what
could be causing this it's like
i don't know but at a certain point
maybe you should be like
we're seeing something here fauci gets
asked about it and he's like i don't
know
okay well i mean the government has had
such a
a bad reaction to or bad
uh policy whatever you want to call it
to covid since the beginning
i'm still of the opinion that they were
they proved themselves to be unreliable
and not worth trusting
when they were telling people not to
wear masks and then did the complete
reversal
especially seeing as it seems to me if i
understand correctly
the reason they were telling people not
to wear masks was because
they were concerned about whether or not
people in the
uh in the medical field would have
enough they're literally lying to the
american people about things they
believed
would be helpful because essentially it
was triage you know
right he said this yeah he said like we
just want to make sure the medical
community
got their masks so i don't trust the
government at all you know about you
know kind of look i'm i'm middle of the
road right
i i gotta say the things that i find
bothersome are
you got a lot of tribalistically pro-vax
people taking their selfies
and like gloating and smiling you get
brian stella and cnn saying
why won't fox news post selfies with
their vaccines and i'm like
dude you're making it worse if you talk
to your doctor if your doctor recommends
it
go with what your doctor says i was
talking to somebody and they said their
doctor actually recommended against it
because you know
wife was pregnant and they were
concerned about allergies and things
like that and i'm like your doctor knows
better than anybody
but then there are people who are like
mad at me because i'm like talk to your
doctor and if it's right for you
only your doctor can tell you and i got
tons of friends who are posting vaccine
selfies
i roll my eyes guys it's like just i get
it you got your vaccine congratulations
yeah it really is i mean look they're
saying covet might replace the flu we
know it's more serious than the flu we
know it's
infectious but i get it
like i'm not gonna go to the doctor and
then post selfies and like join this
tribal crowd i think everybody's just
trying to play tribal politics on this
one it's really simple
that kind of stuff talk to your doctor
it's just absolute cringe
yeah it's uh it's fine if you want to
get
the vaccine i'm likely to get one in the
next week or two if i can get one in new
hampshire i'll be getting one
um do you know which brand you're gonna
get not the
one that comes with free blood clots
that was the estrogenic one
dude i saw this really amazing meme
video
it is really funny it's this dude and
he's like
he's it's it's him acting all the scenes
he's one of these tick-tock meme videos
and he's like he's playing playing the
patient sitting there like you know half
like lazily and the doctor you know
gives him the the the vaccine he's like
there you all you're there you go you're
all set then he goes
i've done it i've collected all five
and then he's like wait what do you mean
and he goes i've gotten the
pfizer the modern the astrazeneca the
johnson and johnson and the souffle or
whatever
and then the doctor's like you need to
go to the emergency room when you go and
then he punches the doctor in the face
and he's like why be immune when you can
be invincible
and then a guy runs in he's a cop and
then he like uses telekinesis on him it
was a great meeting
i wish i remember the guy's name was
funny i just uh a long story short
because uh uh i'm just kind of like look
they have new flu shots every year and
again i know the flu is
is is not nearly like covets worse i
think that the mortality is like double
or triple
but like i don't go to walgreens and
like take pictures and like dance around
and like all the meme stuff within the
hospital it's just
look man i've always been rather
anti-establishment
and i guess to a certain degree punk
rock
i just i cringe at this like we're all
holding hands under the rainbow and
there's a doctor and post these selfies
the i mean look it's it's bad that
people have lost their lives and
and have lost their you know their their
uh
their jobs and and their businesses and
stuff um
one of the more first world problems is
just the level of cringe
has gone through the roof because of
covet the amount of people that are
you know the the whole superheroes
bowing to doctors picture that
i mean it's just um you know i'm i'm for
if you if your doctor says you should
get the vaccine i'm forgetting it i'm
gonna get it because
i will do almost anything to get back on
tour again because i miss touring so
much i love playing shows
that's it's not just my livelihood i i
love performing
so if i got to get a vaccine to get on
the road again okay
fine but man if i see one more person
wearing two masks in their their default
picture
on in their bathroom oh it's just like
come on
come on these are you know it's i get
that that you want to do this but it's
all this this tribal virtue signal stuff
it's just
you're gonna vomit the weird the weird
thing to me is like uh
i understand if people are concerned
about the vaccine because it's under
emergency use
use authorization so it's not gone
through final approval
sure sure i'm just like talk to your
doctor but
you know i think most of the people that
have come through here in the past month
have gotten their vaccines yeah and
we've like talked about it and they're
like oh yeah you know
like it's not a big deal and i'm like
what's this
i wouldn't call it anti-vaxx i would
call it there's like people who don't
trust
what's you know vaccine and it's kind of
weird to me so i'm like i don't know
dude talk to your doctor
i get it like you're allowed you're
allowed to do what you want read what
you want
but i just feel like the way i've always
explained it is i went to my doctor a
year ago and he prescribes me some like
crazy
you know i don't know what it's called
and i'm like it's like this weird long
word and i'm like
sounds good to me and now people are
like all of a sudden i'm concerned about
this i'm like dude
i i think i think the vaccine passport
stuff goes over the top very very
very very over the top yeah like it's be
it's be you know yeah
but i i think your medical history is
your medical issue you talk to your
doctor your doctor tells you what to do
talk to a bunch of doctors i don't
i don't i i think we i think we've been
a dead horse on this one but let's let's
do this
you mentioned you want to go back on
tour absolutely man
check this out cdc director says
michigan needs to shut down
again amid rising chronovirus cases and
will not be able to vaccinate its way
out of a fourth spike come on man
i feel like i got people saying like
tim's shilling for vaccines and i'm like
dude i've gotten a ton of vaccines
before i don't get it
man i want that flint when they come
back out
and they're like oh even if you get the
vaccine we're still shutting the state
down i'm like what am i supposed to tell
people
if i can't go outside why do i need the
vaccine
if you're telling me i can't go out i
can't go to the store all right well
once we start reopening i'll call my
doctor and say what do you think i got
food allergies
that was always like the the issue for
me on this i'm like i'm not gonna and
i'm
35 man i'm not in the affected group but
if they were like we're gonna reopen
everything
and you know it's easier if you get your
vaccine then i'll be like all right cool
you know we're getting back to the movie
theaters and all that stuff you're not
gonna wear a mask
but they're telling me i gotta wear two
masks and i can't go outside but go get
it anyway i'm like i'm chill i'll wait
like i don't understand i'm not trying
to be a dick i'm not trying to be like
anti-vex in any way i'm just saying i
mean i got time
you know what i mean yeah again it comes
back to the the the mistrust of or at
least for me
it comes back to the mistrust of
government because they've had had such
a bad even if it's just messaging the
messaging has been
so just abhorrently terrible just
disgusting
and right you're gonna have people that
don't you know that don't trust
what they're saying and i mean i'm not i
don't
feel like i should be expected to know
what to do
i yell at a stick for a living right
like i sing in a band
like i am not i'm not the guy to ask or
to
to tell you what you should do when it
comes to vaccinations
i don't know i have to go by what i read
and by what i hear
and if if you're only going by what you
read and what you hear you're
literally basing your opinion on someone
else's opinion
right you know it's your goat you're
saying this guy i trust and this is what
i've heard from this guy
and so when it gets to people on you
know on twitter being
you know rude and stuff like that or or
having the you know acting like they're
so much better than other people because
they're like oh this is what i believe
and
you are so dumb for taking the vaccine
because all the stuff that goes in there
you're so dumb for not taking the
vaccine because
wha what do you know you work at
you work at the pretzel place in the
mall shut your face
you know like you know you know i love
it's like your doctor could literally
prescribe you like frazzo
basil bam shove it up your ass that's
the thing yeah and people are like you
gotta duck
yeah i'm like it's between you and your
doctor man i don't wanna know about that
and then because their doctor
recommended it they're gonna talk to you
like you're a [ __ ]
because you're not taking the
suppository right you can also get a
second opinion that's a big part of the
medical industry in fact you're often
not on twitter you're entitled to one
then you get banned if a doctor tells
you something and you question it
that's your right and you also have the
right to then a second and maybe a third
opinion and to look to other doctors and
you should be researching if you're
going to stick stuff in your body what
you're doing with it uh
i'm just mad at fauci because he has
been the biggest discouraging factor in
all of this
it's just like come on dude like texas
and florida are doing all right
you know what i mean i just came from
texas and and there are still
some of the some of the larger chain
stores like walmart you still have to
wear a mask and stuff but smaller places
and and
uh you know smaller businesses you you
know people don't wear them and it's not
you know you don't see a lot of people
freaking out and i think there's there
might be something to the
idea that you know texas is you know
hitting 80s and 90s now so people are
outside
and and not cooped up and maybe that
does have something to do with it but
again
that's not how what the hell do i know i
i sing in a band i can only go by what
i'm what i'm seeing you know yeah
florida taxes are warm
and so it could be california though
yeah well it could be
you're outside you're less likely to
transmit perhaps yeah but again
not a doctor like like i said man
doctors prescribe you some weird stuff
but you know what we borrowed a lot of
money to be able to do that stuff go
go talk to them and get your insurance
company to give them some money so they
can pay back their loans
but what's worrying to me is that at a
certain point people are just not going
to care anymore
and there was this one thing i think was
on cnn where this woman was like now is
our chance to get the vaccine out
because if we don't
terrifying they're like people are going
to go out and do their own thing anyway
enjoy their freedoms the worst thing
about that is is
the just she misunderstands what the
role of government is misunderstands
anything about human liberty
misunderstands
why people are free thinks that that
your the government gets its power from
the existence of the government as
opposed to the consent of the governed i
mean
it is just listening to that that
person go on i i i was appalled it was
it was one of the most
one of the most offensive things that
i've heard in ages and i'm not easily
offended
yeah it's like they're going to enjoy
their freedom anyway so now's our chance
like yeah come on dude
well uh how about we get into one of the
most dangerous stories for youtube
as it were because uh hey if it's the
news it's in the news and
who am i to judge we have this story
from the daily mail you ready for this
one let's go
pentagon scientists reveal a microchip
that senses covid19 in your body before
you show symptoms
and a filter that extracts the virus
from your blood gimme
i can't believe it when i saw this meme
going around i'm like that's not
can't be real i can't believe that's an
actual story that that is being
i mean i'm surprised that that it hasn't
been you know squashed by google and in
all the other uh 60 minutes yeah it's a
60-minute story
it's a 60-minute story story no
let me read let me let me read a little
bit let me read this
pentagon scientists working inside a
secretive unit set up at the height of
the cold war have created a microchip
to be inserted under the skin which will
detect coveted 19 infections the mark of
the beast
they're putting robots in you and a
revolutionary filter that can remove the
virus from the blood
when attached to a dialysis machine does
it have lights on it does that are they
shooting lights in your vein like trump
said they're gonna put it
bleach the team at darpa have been
working
for years on preventing and ending
pandemics they assess the issues and
come up with ingenious solutions which
at times appears to be more science
fiction
be a science fiction novel than working
in a laboratory one of their recent
inventions they told 60 minutes on
sunday night
was a microchip which detects covet
infection
in an individual before it can become an
outbreak the microchip is sure to spark
worries among
some about a government agency
implanting a microchip
in a citizen by by some they mean jesus
people
there's some people that are very
religious
i'm pretty sure they mean everyone
except these like just i don't know bill
gates is on
is like yeah let's do it i want to chip
in everyone do you remember vera chip
this was like 10 years ago i think
vaguely like 50 vaguely refresh my
memory
they're rfid chips they would implant in
your hand oh yeah and you could wave it
by a door
and it had your information on it and
the way it works is that
the signal emitted from the reader
provides enough power for it to bounce
back a signal with information
it's brilliant but when that came out
this is like two thousands people were
freaking out like
this is it this is the mark of the beast
there are already biohackers that have
have done that kind of stuff
though yeah i mean there's people who
put like full weird like arduinos like
in their arm your body rejects that
stuff
yeah but like this stuff has been around
for a while where there's been some kind
of microchip and
betting and there's been all the
conspiracy theorists and the funny thing
is
there's a meme going around because of i
think ryan reynolds where he posted a
vaccine selfie
and he said upgraded to 5g today
now i'm seeing all of my like i'm seeing
some of my friends and a bunch of memes
or people are like getting 5g
reception's great
and i'm like i get it i get it it's a
funny joke but the thing is
we the media was desperately trying to
tell people
even youtube was against the rules
they're not putting microchips there's
no microchips there's no covered
microchip stop
and then it's like okay fine okay we
won't say it's crazy we know it's crazy
and then sunday
60 minutes and it's microchips
it's okay for 60 minutes to do it too
yes
this conversation probably got this this
stream defunded i wouldn't be surprised
if we get in trouble for something like
this
because you know it happens the way
youtube videos are moderated
it's typically some dude in like india
or you know china or mexico
and it's outsourced labor where some of
these people
is it really oh yeah yeah my
understanding is i'll put it that way
just in case because you know
but my understanding is it's outsourced
labor because there's so much content
so you get some person who's watching it
and they don't understand context
first you the robots that do it and the
robots are like i see swears
boop demonetized then if it escalates
you'll get a review from like a person
and they're going to be like oh
microchips that's conspiracy
theory boop boop demonetized not anymore
this happens to me all the time though
check it out so i actually have
uh i actually know people at google but
i have a i have an actual like
google rep that i have to constantly
message like hey this is demonetized
there was uh we had two videos on this
show on this on on this channel where we
criticized ocasio-cortez
we got demonetized because of it and
they said you violated our policy
against
being hateful towards an individual
she'll send people to your house
what aoc yeah that guy there was there
was that uh
a person that was on twitter that made a
comment critical of
aoc and the police showed up at his fbi
shut up really
you didn't hear about this yeah i forgot
i don't remember the guy's name
um he was a left-leaning guy and he was
he was he said something critical and he
ended up with uh
with someone at the fbi at his house
about the uh
because he was he criticized aoc so i
don't think that it was aoc
thanks for sending it back to be fair
the first story that pops up is actually
they tweeted about some something really
bad
it was like causing harm to something
spicy uh
yeah yeah i i'd say it was spicy so
that's if you google search aoc fbi
something i probably can't repeat on
youtube because
let's not go there yeah yeah it wasn't
just a guy saying like aoc you suck it
was a guy who said something like go do
a thing to this person you know what i
mean
interesting you see it you see the story
somebody was basically calling for harm
against aoc
yeah i mean i'm looking look at that i'm
looking at this now
or is that a different because the one i
saw was from a couple months ago no no
this is
yeah this is not the one that i'm that
i'm referring to
um so there is a story where a guy was
being mean to her well anyway
while you look that up i'll just finish
off this point
they demonetize these stories because we
were critical of aoc yes
and then i submitted for appeal and they
were confirmed demonetized
so then i had to contact google and like
hey and then it took like a week and
they were like
sorry about this they're monetizing that
wasn't against the rules i'm like
we're criticizing a politician dude you
know like what can we say unsettling
in this case we're talking about
microchips that the pentagon has
announced
on 60 minutes 60 minutes cbs is that cbs
that's cbs are you going to get the
microchip i am not going to get the
microphone i want to know what is a
proprietary software
i will i will get the neodymium magnets
in my fingertips oh i am sold
you know you know about that no do you
know about this biohacking thing no
if they if they cut open your fingertip
yeah and they put like a
it's like a a coated neodymium magnet a
small one
and then they sew your fingers up and
when it heals the
the magnet vibrates against
electromagnetic fields
so it gives you electrosense what so you
can actually put your hand on a wall and
feel where the power cables are
because and apparently it feels
different gimme like it's a new sense
something you're like whoa i've never
felt something like this yeah because
what happens is
the magnet is pulling and pushing
against the nerve from the inside and
vibrating
so you can like feel like the the emf
waves the
electromagnetic waves coming off of
electric electric objects and devices
lydia looks horrifying it's cool it's
cool the problem is
your body rejects foreign objects so for
a lot of people
what happens is eventually your fingers
just spit them out yeah they just get
pushed further and further out
so there are some techniques they tried
doing they coat it into materials that
your body ignores it
some of the early pioneers of this have
had the magnets break in their fingers
and you gotta get them removed and
there's like infection risks
and your fingertips are particularly
sensitive so getting them sliced open
for the surgery hey man
but uh man i've always thought that was
really cool now microchips
i will get neurolink will you get
normally i will i don't know that i'll
get first gen
did you see the monkey playing pong no
dude
amazing and it's at the end of the video
can we go from being very scared about
government planning microchips
talking about monkeys playing he's
[ __ ] good at it he's doing it with
his mind is it a chimp
it's a yeah i don't trust the government
but elon daddy elon i tell you what
there's there's a totally different kind
of
deal going on with you he's open
sourcing the code and you know what it's
tracking and what it's not tracking he
can open source the code but i'm still
relying on someone else to tell me
because i can't code
so like you could you could be like oh
you know look look you can look at the
code it's like people say oh
you can look at the bitcoin ledger and
see i'm like no you can look at the
bitcoin legendary i can't
i can't that that's all german or
whatever
i don't our president speaks english
doesn't speak foreign language he relies
on an interpreter the interpreter may as
well be the president hold on our
president he says not speaking
come on man used to journey to pressure
he speaks
elon musk's company says this monkey is
playing pong with his mind
this video is lit the monkey
also so i will mention it do you know
what an eeg is
electrons so you can actually buy them
they've been around for a long long time
long time but this there's consumer
grade ones
i i talked about this before we bought
one where it's a band that goes over
your head and then there's like a bar
that goes onto your forehead
and it can detect two different waves i
guess
and so there's a a a reader
an eg reader on the computer and there
was a red and blue line and they're like
bouncing randomly
and it's like focus and concentration or
whatever i don't know what it means
and me and my friend we put this with
the eeg on
and we're like trying to focus and the
lines are just random no it's actually
horny and hungry
yeah no matter no matter what we do we
couldn't get the lines to move
but then we gave it to his sister and
she put it on and she could move the red
line
like she figured out real quick and like
the line would like make the line go up
and then she would look at it and the
line would go up
very hungry very super hungry so we were
wondering
if these two outputs could be used to
control a drone
so that you have two controls one is to
make it go up
and down and the other is to make it
rotate so you couldn't fly it around
because you'd need
more sensors but with just that
instead of a red line on the screen the
drone could be going up and down
so i bring that up because that wasn't
invasive
it's a headband you'd put on you can buy
all these things right now
does the monkey really need to get his
brain chipped
to be able to play pong the answer is no
he doesn't he does so that way
eventually you can wear it in your head
and type on your phone without your
fingers
aren't you worried about being turned
into the borg no no
no why do you want the newer link
because i want to because i think that
that elon musk is right
about the interface that to me that's
really the the
the interesting thing the interface that
we have today with the internet
is limited to most people as their
thumbs you know you we
like he said he you used to have a full
keyboard for walking around all the time
that it's gone down to your thumbs if
you can manage to just
interface with the with the with the
phone or whatever in your pocket
without having the slowness of your
thumbs and you could just
access the existing internet by thinking
that's something that i find
extremely intriguing and i think would
be a
very useful uh useful thing to have in
your day-to-day life i'm not looking to
be like oh i want the internet in my
brain or whatever
having that but having that interface
from from that removes my hands
you know the necessity of having my
hands do the typing
to access the internet internet that i i
think is is interesting don't you want
to download kung fu
like in the matrix i i love the idea i
do
um but i also think that there is a
certain amount of
uh of of well i mean i suppose they
could
you know eventually if you could if that
is possible you could download the
the muscle memory and stuff right you
need muscle memory and you need the
muscle proteins to actually build up to
be able to do half the thing
sure so it's not just about you know
it's funny when people are like in the
matrix he
plugs thing in his brain he downloads
kung fu and then he can fight he's like
i know kung fu or whatever
it's like well hold on hold on i can
watch someone do something
and they can explain it to me and then
my brain's like got it and then i'll
fall lower cause i'm not flexible enough
and i'm not strong enough i just started
taking jiu jitsu
about a month ago and there is a
significant learning curve to
i don't even know what i'm supposed to
do like for me if i like right now i'm
at i'm basically at a point where if i
can pass
guard on someone that i'm that i'm
rolling with and i'm like okay i feel
like i've won
i i don't know what to do so not knowing
so but having the information there
would be cool and knowing okay this is
what i'm looking to do
but the actual executing still would
take some kind of
you know some amount of of
physical work i think bro what if you're
actually like a five foot three morbidly
obese dude
plugged into a neural link right now
because you've always your whole life
wanted to be a famous heavy metal singer
and you're in the game right now well
you know then hopefully
you know he never wakes up at least you
can say you can enjoy yourself playing a
video game
not because you know people talk about
you get the neural link you plug in and
you're like
in skyrim you're you're in world of
warcraft or call of duty or whatever
yeah you know i don't think that i think
with with the with vr headsets and stuff
like that that's not
super far away um sensations like smell
that you get when you know if you're in
a pla the the way things smell in a
place are
i don't know that we could reproduce
that um but neuralink possibly could
by accessing those those parts of your
brain and then you go ahead and you know
you put on a
vr helmet with that for the sound in
sight i mean you know that they're
actually working on virtual smell
by causing electrical stimulation in
your ear in your inner ear
i tell you those things that tinder
would would the use tinder use would go
way down if that stuff was real like
right now in like we're in a simulation
in the real world phil you're actually
like some 23 year old just like fat
fat kid and you're like i always wanted
to be a heavy metal singer and you're in
the game
ian's actually like a tech billionaire
who's really smart and clean cut
and he's like i just wanted to be this
like free-spirited dmt crazy guy in a
podcast so bad
it's like you know it's just you're like
i'm schooling these dudes
well so no like not what i mean is like
i'm very hypothetical obviously but you
know if it's possible to create
a virtual environment where you get to
experience that game
you know you're not already in it yeah i
mean i've heard people talk about the
the idea that it's a simulation and
stuff like that musk talks about it yeah
i mean what if he's trying to break out
of the simulation well then
i want him to i i i i truly
think that elon musk is like is a
i think that he's he's a probably a
pretty good dude
who isn't you know isn't like the people
at google
yeah i tweeted i tweeted tax the rich
and then all the lefties were like yeah
and then a bunch of conservatives like
haha very funny tim
and then i tweeted tax the rich but give
all the money to elon musk
and they're like okay now the left side
happens they don't like him yeah they
don't like him at all just but they
don't like him because he has money and
he's successful and people on the left
are
you know yeah i was really annoyed when
he blasted the tesla into space and like
this is so
dumb and i'm like well he needed a
payload he needed a weight and he made
something really cool and inspirational
for young people
that's legit you know yeah so i i you
know i'm fine with it
i don't like the idea that you got all
these billionaires dumping money into
politics
so take it all just give it to elon musk
and let them build a spaceship to mars i
want to see that
you know when when when people like
bernie when someone like bernie sanders
criticizes elon musk
really really rubs me the wrong way
because bernie sanders has done nothing
but live off of the of other people's
money his entire life he's produced
nothing of value
uh he wrote a book yeah you're right and
then he made a million dollars off of
his book yeah and
and he is uh then he stopped talking
about the millionaires and the
billionaires
no no no no no no just the billionaires
yeah now he talks he brought him back
though he brought it back
did he really i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry sorry you were right you're right
he's not talking about the millionaires
yeah
yeah
it's just the billionaires that he's got
a problem but then he brought
millionaires back recently because if
you write a book
you know then you could maybe make a
million dollars don't you
but me i made a million dollars selling
my book
at a 37 tax rate you know
top market yeah so it's really funny too
i'm kind of stoked on this the media's
collapse
because there's this big up upset uh
everyone's angry about uh sub stack
sub stack is where writers can charge a
fee
and write articles it's really simple
but now you get these high profile
individuals leaving their main outlets
and just doing sub stacks they're
leaving because the main outlets are
garbage
and they're being restricted and they'll
make money it's like youtube
like i worked for vice i worked for
fusion and people are you know i i loved
this i loved this there was some some
like new york journalists and
and they tweeted at me they tagged me in
this they were like remember remember
tim cast man whatever happened to him
and then someone's like
this was like this was like a year and a
half ago or two years ago and they were
like to go from like this high-profile
six-figure
like you know corporate media job to now
what and someone goes like oh man
his patreon is only bringing a thousand
bucks a month they're like wow that's
sad
and i'm like these people know nothing
about what's going on
they live in this bubble where working
for the machine is like the ideal
and i left and started a youtube channel
and i was like i was on joe rogan and
like doing really well
and i was you know business was it was
expanding and exploding and that's
better than ever
and these people just live in that
bubble so now these new thoughts are
freaking out
because sub stack has just taken
everything away from them but i'm glad
i'm glad
they're they're in free fall their
ratings are collapsing and i think
what's happening is a lot of people like
to say that these
these media companies get woke and then
go broke
they think vice got woke and then went
broke they think these media companies
decided one day
we're gonna be awoke oh no our money's
gone some of them went the other way
some of them were going broke and
decided to get woke in desperation
they're like our ratings are dropping
what do we do pander what we pander to i
don't know progressives
at least we'll make we'll maintain that
what was that tumblr
yeah yeah we got like uh there's a story
in the new york times
i don't think i'll get to i don't think
we need to get too much into this one
uh look at this new york times uh writes
a guide to neo
pronouns are you a person place or thing
we have good news
um we're all persons yeah yeah are are
you a place
hold on what do you think i'm a place so
this image they have this is the new
york times mind you
it's an image and it's the new york
times yeah pre
print prince and print self
no no no and go f yourself well hold on
hold on hold on
if someone there there are some
limitations if someone came to me and
said refer to me as your majesty or
prince whatever i'd be like
would you refer to me as lord no i'm a
scottish lord
yes i bought ten lord did you ten by ten
foot by ten foot
i'll use whatever preferred pronoun
someone wants i have no intention
to be rude i'm not interested in in
in upsetting people i'm not interested
and i don't have i don't have a
you know i don't have the desire to be
like no there's only biological men and
biological women and
not interested at all if you have a
your own pronoun you're probably an
annoying person anyway so i don't want
to hang out with you
so if someone came to me and said i
actually i met someone at occupy
they said you know uh z said refer to me
as z zer
and i was like okay i don't care
whatever sure i just you know i just i
just called by that by their name
some of these people also made up their
own names and i'm like if you're 25
and you're like my name is you know
hamsters you know hamster friend i'm
like
you sure yeah i'll call you whatever you
want i'm just like i hear you right all
right you got it hamster bro
exactly i'll call you whatever you want
but i will call you
very infrequently if i have you right
now i i remember this was funny because
it became a thing and some people were
like
they were like i don't know that's kind
of i've never never heard that like
we're supposed to remember that and i
was like
oh you ain't gonna forget you know i was
just like i'm sitting there like my eyes
half clothes like it's like occupied
while i'm outside i'm sleeping outside
i'm like this is the last thing i care
about
i was like dude i will call you whatever
you want you can call me susan if it
makes you happy i literally don't care
this is like the last thing on my mind
the cops are burning their horns right
now i'm gonna go get cheeseburger
i it like didn't even occur to me until
started becoming a thing and now the new
york times is writing about it
and it's amazing because they mentioned
that like apparently someone
a long time ago tried to make it the
pronoun
for like non-descript individuals i
guess and they're they're
look they're saying like it's a new
thing with young people
you have to respect it otherwise you're
like transphobic and all that stuff i'm
like
dude like a young woman who identifies
as a woman but calls herself like
you know gordon gordo and gordo self
like
that's not anything to do with like
transgender anything no
the you know the idea that
there are there is a a significant
portion of the trans community that
actually does have their own
specific pronouns if i understand
correctly the vast majority of the trans
community out there
just wants to pass they just want to be
like if you're a trans woman
you just want to be you just want to
pass and you want to be called she
i totally respect that if you're a trans
man you just want to pass
you want to be called heat totally
respect that
that's totally fine i again i'm not
interested in
in demanding that someone go by the
pronouns of their you know of what they
were born as like that or what they were
assigned at birth or whatever i i'm not
interested in in messing up someone's
day like that
um and so i think that it's really
mostly activists
and people that are that are looking to
or i think it's mostly activists that
are looking to make
a specific uh personalized pronoun
or or something that is is unique or
whatever and it's like okay
i mean you can and i again if i if if
you have
pronouns that you need me to use i'll
use them but i'm probably going to be
like
this person is a lot of work to be
around yeah yeah
uh i think one of the issues is that
there's no way to broach the subject
without being
accused of being transphobic because
there's actually two different
transgender communities
or i should say two different trans
perspectives on this
there are some prominent trans people
who mention
that they view gender as binary hence
they're transitioning between male or
female
they they they'll say there's like
degrees in between or something but for
the most part
i think it's like the millennial and
older transgender people some prominent
leftists i'm not going to name them
they've already got cancelled several
times but they've pointed out
that uh they believe there's he she
and if you want to go by that's fine
what happened was this particular trans
woman
got cancelled because the younger
generation said you're being transphobic
for not respecting neo pronouns
natalie i'm not gonna say who i'm not
gonna i don't wanna i don't wanna cause
a dragging thing where they're like look
at this video and he called this person
and
made all these things up so you know he
said this about this person and they go
into a brigade no i don't want to get
involved in that
i just want to point out the difference
here's what they say at the new york
times
they say one card explains neopronouns
at length
in its facts section it provides a
response used often in the neo-pronoun
community
when talking to people who claim
neo-pronouns aren't real words
yes literally every word is made up neo
pronouns are real
because they carry meaning and are
understood by others that's
the problem they're not i don't
understand half these words and if you
said it to me i'd be like i don't know
what that is
i don't know what you're trying to tell
me
if someone said they were their pronouns
were pre-print
i'd be like i don't understand like that
that doesn't mean anything to me and
and like you're saying part of the part
of the usefulness of words is the
meaning behind them
if so the issue becomes
neo-pronouns just get rid of pronouns in
general because if
ian tells me his pronouns are pre-prin
and so instead of saying you know he
said
he was mad at himself i'd say pre said
pre was mad at prince self it's harder
to understand what i'm saying and think
about it and communicate
maybe that's on purpose maybe they're
trying to exert power maybe these are
young people who want to you know
assert themselves in a conversation but
if if
everyone here gave me a different
pronoun i wouldn't be able to be like oh
i was talking to ian yeah priest said
that
prince yeah he was saying he wanted to
go to the mall because he was mad at
himself for not buying
you know his uh his second set of shot
glasses which part of the
which is part of the point that i made
about you know i'll say whatever
you want me to say for your pronoun but
it is difficult
to engage with you if you have your own
specific pronouns because there's a
certain amount of
you know when you read you just
you don't re sound out the words that
you know the word
and so you see the word you identify it
and it does you know
you know what it says because you're
familiar with the whole word
um and our brains work like that when it
comes to talking too
we don't have to think about the words
we're going to use
you have to think about the idea and
maybe how to articulate it but you're
not thinking about how do i say
this if you have a new word in your
lexicon
or if there's a special word for a
person you have to really put
thought thought into it so it does
become an awkward way of speaking it's
like telling you you have four names
but now not one thing that's happening
where the left is getting angry people
started calling themselves their
pronouns are blm and blm self
so you'd be you'd be like oh i was
talking to ian blm said that
blm was mad at blm self for not buying
blm's
second whiskey set whiskey glasses
i get it and they're doing a cab and a
capsule
oh good good so i'm glad
thank you i love it all right well i'm
going to read more
many people who use neopronouns don't
just use one set they select a handful
and show off their collections on
websites like pronoun pronounie.xyz
a site that provides usage examples for
neo pronouns
users make their own pronony pages like
this one which includes z
zem zer moon moon self star star self bb
self and bun bun self
sorry if i have too many pronouns the
page creators wrote one self is
from now on call me bun bun self okay
mine now
i like it i'm i i do like bun self but
like
basically for rabbits not for anybody
else okay that'd be cute yeah yeah
bun wanted you know bun was telling me
bun wanted more carrots for oneself
i love it you can use you can use just
one set
or they them if there are too many
so here's where it gets interesting i
know a lot of people think this is silly
i'm down for respecting people within
certain contexts
you know behind closed doors we have to
make fun of each other we don't like
every not everybody likes each other but
we try to be good to each other the best
of our abilities at least i think that's
a good thing
you're out in public you see someone you
don't like you smile and you nod then
you go behind closed door and say they
smelled like farts
whatever of course so if someone comes
up to me and they're like is my protons
but you got it you know i got no beef
but
if i'm not hanging out with you i'm
going to be like i mean i i i think this
here's why i think it's it becomes a
problem many states are passing these
laws that say
your company these jobs have to use your
pronouns
that's it it's in the law i actually i
i'm you know i'ma stop
i like this i'm a fan you know why this
is legit culture jamming
this is exploiting the system and
pointing out the holes and how they
don't work
so in new york you are entitled at your
job
or as a customer to have your pronouns
your name respected
it's a civil it's a human rights law in
new york city if you work at say
you know starbucks and you demand to
have a certain set of pronouns
they have to use them otherwise they're
violating your human rights it's a
violation of your gender expression
okay so to what limit if the new york
times is straight up saying you can use
50 different pronouns
your manager better start doing it so
i'm like okay let's play that game let's
my i i encourage people to adopt
pronouns that they feel comfortable with
and make something of it i guess i you
know i
i get what you're saying but i i think
that that eventually
uh and probably very quickly will become
detrimental to the
to the actual trans community because
the more difficult you make it for
people to
navigate polite society the less
interested people will be in being
polite
they're gonna say well it's just too
much of a pain in the dick so
pardon my french and they're just gonna
be like you know
screw it i'm just gonna do you know
whatever i'm not worried about this
person's you know blah blah and then
actual
you know people that that have trained
you know have transitioned that
you know genuinely do get their feelings
hurt if they're misgendered and stuff
like that
they're going to be the people that are
going to pay the price yeah you know and
i think that
that there are there is a certain to
some to a certain degree there are
people that will do
things like have their own pronouns
their own personal pronouns
for a narcissistic reason and they're
going to hurt actual trans
people and they're going to they're
going to end up making it bad for people
that are
you know actually trans i've actually
mentioned this i was telling the story
about new york
when the story first was breaking it was
like a few months after the law was
passed
i started exploring what new york city
had said in terms of
pronouns and they said any any and so i
actually
talked i reached out some friends i said
i need to find a human rights lawyer
like someone who
litigates and like actually understands
this and some advocates and
there's a lot of confusion but i spoke
with one lawyer who basically said
if you tried gaming the system and
making up some ridiculous pronoun
they would laugh you out of court and i
was like so if i went to a restaurant
and i used some ridiculous like asian
stereotype for like me and my family
and you know just like offensive words i
and they said i refuse to say these
things you think if i sued the judge
would say
get out of here you're screwing with us
i think i disagree totally but well so
this lawyer said
there's a reason why we have laws and we
have judges judges interpret the law
if the judge sees that you're making a
mockery of the law
they will just say oh we get it it's not
legitimate complaint
and then i said so you're saying if i
dress in a way that is deemed to be
a joke or illegitimate the judge can
just throw me out and he goes yes and i
said
so what happens if an actual trans
person walks up to a judge and the judge
says you're not a woman
and then says get out of my courtroom
that that opens the door for them to
actually
suppress transgender rights and that's
when the lawyer was like
well you know these things like the
general idea from the lawyer was
it's true they could happen but
most of these judges understand the
spirit of the law
and i was like listen i'm willing to bet
there's going to be a conservative judge
in one of these jurisdictions
and if you're telling me they have a
right to laugh someone out of the
courtroom it will be an actual trans
person
yep yeah i guess especially if you're
looking at people now who are becoming
aggravated by
the excessivity of it uh they become
judges in the future
you know the right 17 year olds now are
gonna be judges in 20 years i don't i
don't and the thing is i don't know
that it's actually really
excessive i think that things like that
story again are
such a small case like there are such a
very few people that would want to be
you think that do you think that it
would be more than you think i was i was
just gonna
i physically express myself while you're
talking just so you know i'm gonna have
a counterpoint but uh
this is from tumblr 10 years ago it's
now in the new york times it is
but i still don't think that there's a
lot of people that that would be using
their own personalized
because i mean we already talked about
the fact that most trans people just
want to pass
yeah and they just want to be they want
to live their life
as you know as as a trans woman or as a
trans man that's that's
that's it i and i think that the a
very small minority want the specialized
uh you know specialized pronouns and i
do think that that
is more about narcissism
than about actually being transgender i
think that it's more about i want to be
you know i want attention i think you
hit the nail now with this one that it's
ultimately going to be
more detrimental for trans people yeah i
think it's a hard trance community well
let's let's let's jump to the last i i
was just i was i was saving the best for
lasts because
i'm going to go off on this one all
right we got the story about the falcon
and the winter soldier you may have seen
it's a new disney plus show
and get well go broke baby because the
last rumor report
we were covering is that there was this
scene in the show
it's the falcon and the winter soldier
from the avengers movies they're walking
down the street and they're arguing and
it's the falcons of black dude and the
winter soldier's white dude
some cops pull up out of nowhere and
they walk up to bucky the white guy and
they're like is everything okay sir
and he's like yeah it's fine is this man
giving you trouble and they're like
what are you talking about and then sam
is like what's going on and the cops are
like sir sir calm down
and then bucky's like don't you know who
this is and the cops are like oh
man oops it was the avenger oh geez
according to the rumor
this obvious black lives matter
narrative
soured a bunch of people who turned the
show off and stopped watching
i don't know if that's true or not
that's a rumor but apparently we're
hearing a lot i'm seeing a lot of posts
on twitter from people who are like i
just couldn't do it it's so
over the top and absurd had nothing to
do with the plot at all literally it was
like
they're like we gotta stop these super
soldiers man and the cops pull up and
they're like hold on there sir we're
gonna do a racism it's like
it had nothing to do with the show right
all right well
we got a new one for you captain america
is an incel
oh here we go baby the rap says in cell
captain america is so perfect
we know it's wrong to enjoy the whiny
and murderous john walker on the falcon
winter soldier
but it feels so right i tweeted the
wokeness
in the falcon and uh in fact the falcon
in which soldier is getting too
thick to be enjoyable because the latest
episode was like
uh zemo who's the bad guy is like this
lady is a super soldier and now she will
be a spoiler alert sorry i guess so if
yeah if you're not ready for this
spoiler alert
anyway i'll continue the the anti-hero
guy zemo he says
she will become a supremacist now that
she has super soldier
you know serum in her veins or whatever
and it was like the idea was basically
that
people who gain power crave it and then
start believing that they're the only
ones who should have power
who can solve the problems and he's like
the nazis believed it the avengers
believe it
and now you've got this rogue group of
you know extremists globalist leftists
who kill innocent people to get their
way
the rep says let me just read some of
this for you john walker
aka the new captain america showed us
his true self on the
falcon which soldier this week in more
ways than one the new cap has struggled
to feel like he belongs
in a world full of gods and aliens and
super soldiers and for good reason
he's just a regular soldier the us
government decided to name the new
captain america
without consulting so far as we know any
current mcu heroes
he hasn't been trained to fight these
battles so of course he's going to get
whooped
and so we have this new captain america
he's just trash at his job he's
embarrassed and certainly looks like he
hasn't been sleeping because of his
frustration at being sidelined by actual
heroes
there's an easy remedy to the issue
partner up with sam and bucky and follow
their lead
but this toxic masculinity captain
america can't do that
he's freaking captain america he's
supposed to be the lead he can't take
orders
from these sidekicks even though they're
better than him at everything
even though they actually fought
superhuman folks and worse before
even though they have some idea how to
operate freely like this and john walker
doesn't the show is called the falcon
and winter soldier
but this guy thinks it should be the
captain america show for most the
episode
the new captain america is a huge clown
seething with rage about his numerous
inadequacies
like some kind of message board in cell
wondering when we're finally going to
talk about men's rights
and then he gets a hold of the final
vial of super soldier's serum
and he puts that stuff in his body and
he graduates to captain clown
they say way back in the first avenger
captain america the creator
of the original serum said that it
amplifies everything that is inside good
becomes great bad becomes worse
steve rogers was good becomes great and
it looks like john walker is the other
one
it's kind of a strange arc for john he
was originally presented as idealistic
and excited to help
but he so quickly went from that to
being a tool without much much of a
devolution
he just he was just he just was a good
guy and then he was yelling at the real
superheroes for being so good at their
jobs
that they're making him look bad but i
like where we ended up
i like seeing this trash person angrily
beat down bad guys because he hates them
so much
and then tarnish the uniform in the
shield by beating a guided death in
front of a crowd
of people to get revenge for his injured
or dead partner
it's disgusting and it felt so
incredibly wrong and it was absolutely a
thrill to watch
i'd love for blah blah blah okay you get
the point all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
thoroughly give this a whopping and a
debunking
i'm actually interested to see the next
episode of captain america
i'm sorry the falcon and the winter
soldier
because you may be thinking to yourself
wow tim this show certainly has gotten
woke and these woke media outlets are
certainly pointing out that captain
america is an incel and
uh i must stop you there what we're
actually getting
if you actually watch the story if you
listen to the words of the characters
is criticism of critical race theory and
the woke left
first and foremost the bad guys are
globalists
they're called the flag smashers they
wear masks
they want there to be no borders and
they're willing to hurt innocent people
to get it
that doesn't sound like incels or the
far right baron zemo
who is the anti-hero they break out of
prison he says
she is a supremacist now that she has
this power
you know basically she's going to think
she's the only one so what ends up
happening is
the narrative presented by the rap is
that captain america
is a regular guy who feels inadequate
because these other super soldiers exist
and these super soldiers are
supremacists who they think they're the
best
and this captain america guy in one
scene looks at bucky barnes
and he says it's so easy for you isn't
it with that serum coursing through your
veins
then he gets a hold of the serum and
takes it and becomes a villain
and you know what i see with this
replace super soldier
with white privilege and you get a guy
who doesn't have it who is jealous of
those who do
who will do anything to have it who
looks in the face of bucky barnes and
says it's just so
easy for you with your white privilege
and then you have these far leftists
who believe they're the only ones who
can save everything because they have
this power like the white progressives
and it sounds to me like captain america
represents critical race theory black
lives matter and the woke left
anger angry at those who have the
privilege they want
and they're willing to do anything to
get it because they hate those they are
whiny losers
and it's funny that the rap sees that
and says this guy's an incel
no he's a guy who was looking at this
world of superheroes that he wasn't a
part of
and angry at them for what they had and
wanted it
and said they don't deserve this i'm the
real hero sounds to me like he's
criticizing white privilege
would you agree sir uh
there's my son i see your point of view
that makes a lot of sense actually
it's very meta and uh pretty interesting
i wonder if the writers were actually
going for like a woke thing because they
did that police thing early on
yeah but i i watched this and when i
first saw zemo say like oh she will be a
supremacist then i was like oh come on
don't go there
like are we really gonna do this are you
gonna make a a thriller about
superheroes turn into a you know
beat you over the head with this
progressive stuff and then i actually
you know
watched through it and now i feel like
they're actually critical of left it's
similar with black panther
black panther was like the left loved it
you saw you've seen black panther yes so
like the left was treating it like this
great accomplishment
you know and it was it was so amazing
but it was actually politically nuanced
it was a a nation with a literal wall
around its borders refusing immigrants
and refugees
versus an ethno supremacist who wanted
to take over the world and supply a
certain race with weapons
and i'm like that's a that's a nuanced
political take i dig it
now we got the falcon and winter soldier
and they're literally doing
what appears to be a mockery of wokeness
i don't know that i mean i i think your
analysis uh
can definitely be it makes it's
reasonable
i don't think the writers are intending
that
but i do think that uh i think that you
probably hit the nail on the head
what if or at least you you you've
managed to
see something that that you know
possibly possibly the writers did not
see
i'm not yeah right right so i'm not
entirely sure the writers thought this
all through
but is it possible it's projection like
so much of what the left and the
critical theorists and the locusts
what people do they project i want it to
be
um i yeah i i suppose that it that it
you know it is
it is possible because it the it does
make sense
um i imagine they would not be happy
to hear that analysis um but is that
captain america
i you know i mean i'm i'm not a fan of
of you know like i i thought wanda
vision was good
and one division i i understand that
they're you know
your criticism of it ar criticism of one
division
is legitimate you know she was the bad
guy first their episodes are trash
not even a real show yeah she's
torturing people yeah and then she's the
good guy
that sounds hot or whatever yeah at this
point
it's it's it sounds like these are these
are mini series it's not a it's not
going to be recurring season or anything
so it's over already it
may as well have been a movie yeah but
it's so amazing that one division
a lot of people pointed out that it's
like a
let me let me stop here and start over
i've i've heard this meme a lot i don't
know if it's true they said a male power
fantasy
is die hard he's he's climbing stepping
in glass got a gun taped to his back and
he's gonna save the day
the guy he's got he's gonna fight back
and defeat the terrorists and a
woman's power fantasy is the romantic
comedy where the woman seems to bumble
about do everything wrong but the guy
ends up falling for her anyway
so you look at wanda vision and it feels
like it fits more of the traditional
female archetype
that she's angry she's mad at everyone
she gets whatever she wants she does
whatever she wants she's torturing
people and
in the end she's still supposed to be
the good guy uh well i mean i'm not sure
if that is the
the female archetype or not but uh it
does probably just an offensive meme
probably just an offensive me um but it
does seem like
i mean i suppose that that again that is
a a legitimate
way of looking at it um but i mean
when i was when i said that that i liked
uh one division uh i suppose that i
i mean that i found it entertaining um i
wasn't
uh i didn't find it i didn't find it
offensive i did
you know because because they are
characters that i cared about you know
like
i cared about uh you know vision and i
cared about
uh wanda maximoff i also think that
because the scarlet witch is one of the
most powerful characters
if not the most powerful character in
the marvel universe i think that what
happens to her
matters um certainly far more than
than what happens to to you know the
in-cell captain america
they come up with and so the story is
more compelling because
yeah i this is a completely new
character that i don't much care for
you know and i i've only watched i
watched the first episode and i haven't
really
watched the any other episodes of falcon
i'm a falcon and winter soldier
i had intended to or i do intend to um
but i was going to wait until there were
more
i got to be honest i'm kind of bored of
it because it feels like
it's like it's it's just too beat here
yeah but the stakes aren't high enough
not enough is happening the characters
don't matter enough there's not enough
high
level anything to it i i agree about the
the characters don't matter enough like
you know vision was a
was an integral character in in you know
from ultron on you know and
same thing with and wanda again being
the most powerful
character in the the marvel universe
means the stakes are higher
we'll see if the get go broke continues
because
with this this article from the rap
whether my my analysis is correct or not
a lot of people just view it as getting
woke and they're not going to want to
watch it yeah it's
preachy i heard uh jeremy on the
quartering talking about people
turning it off and then i think it was
we talked about it as well you guys and
did you talk about uh overlord dvd too
because i went and listened to his
his video on it he's like the progenitor
of the rumor so i don't know if that's
true or not but it was like
it was it was a way to talk about what
was going on with the show in general so
i mean i'm i'm i'm stoked for multiverse
of madness
what is this doctor strange oh yeah
that's right and that's going to have
wanda in it as well right
yeah see i mean they're characters you
care about
i gave up on it man once
marvel all the marvel crap all the
cartoons it's like
it's like cartoons for adults like all
the cg crap like
it's like they they they all they tend
to have this like invincibility behavior
where they're all like there's no fear
the characters aren't afraid so there's
no like yeah
it doesn't feel like uh this it you know
this this impending like danger that you
feel when with a really good hero
that's that's afraid for their life and
fighting for their life
and then in the background of it there's
just all this cartoon stuff going on in
the guys of like cg explosions that are
fake
ships that are fake lasers that aren't
real and it's like
man i play video games for i want to be
interactive if i'm going to be having
that sort of
cartoon but we did we did get a really
important point someone just brought up
in the super chat that i just saw
there's a scene before the cop pulls up
and
while they're arguing and salmon and
wintersol
and bucky are walking and some little
kid goes yo it's black falcon and he
goes
i'm just a falcon you're black [ __ ] it's
like
nah like and that was something you know
so so this is b young mentioning
isn't that anti welcome like i remember
that it didn't get as much play among
the the you know
the the the you know commentators and it
was
legit i'm just falcon and he is just
falcon dude i think anthony mackie kills
it i think falcon's an awesome character
i
i'm stoked for you know i was excited
for the show i just feel like it's not
you know
he got beat up by a tic tac i mean that
was great
i thought that was awesome i like the
character he's cool he's like a military
guy who got this experimental suit it's
legit i think he could have done
like they could have had a better like
introduction for him whatever but i'm
stoked
i really liked that when he was like i'm
just the falcon that's right they're
making that point
and i'll add something else too because
i've been watching a lot of star trek
the next generation i've seen them all a
million times and watch them again
today's episode blew my mind i'm
watching it on the bbc it's like 4 p.m
or whatever
it's the one where uh wharf sun
alexander comes back from the future
to try and teach himself how to be a
warrior and
there's a point where they don't know
it's his future self and he's telling
this uh you know this this kid who's
like you know 10 years old
no one on the federation starship thinks
of you as a human
because you look like a klingon and he's
like and this kid he goes that doesn't
matter goes yes it does
what you look like does matter and i'm
like that's amazing that star trek the
next generation
way back then was anti-woke was critical
of this idea that being judged based on
how you look
mattered and it was like this guy who
was wrong was telling the kid you have
to
you have to leave and be with your own
kind and i'm like they were actually
being critical of the racists
and now it's come full circle and
they're being critical of the left yeah
that i mean that's that's that was that
was you know
that's what the the the
dream of of dr king was you know where
people
were respected for their own humanity
and that was i heard jim
james lindsey talking about this that
during the civil rights movement
you didn't see uh you know
african-americans
walking around talking about their
blackness they were holding signs that
said
i am a man and i remember that yeah
you know and it just it was an appeal to
their humanity it's like look
i'm a person just like you and and
that's i think that that
that seeing the individual is the is the
important way to view people's not
seeing the group that they come from and
i remember that famous quote from from
dr king where he said he said i have a
dream
that one day there will be a black
superhero who isn't called black falcon
he's just
the falcon yes dude disney remember that
one
he said he said that in selma right
marvel and suit and and star wars they
trashed it we watched
uh fantasia 2000 a couple nights ago
and the animation was flat walt disney
was gone the magic of walt disney the
guy who created that animation
style that flowy movement is dead
and you can see that in disney's art
it's he's gone he's not there to oversee
it and to say what's crap
man that company is just in name only
and that that's money gone wrong you
think money in politics is bad
ryan johnson should be put on trial yes
we demand reparations for what he did at
star wars
he shot babylon yeah yeah he should he
should definitely face
uh yeah i mean i'm trying
i'm being i'm being generous by giving
him a trial but you know it should be
it should probably be a you know just a
quick try all right
let's uh let's go to super chats
everybody if you have not already
do us a solid and smash that like button
because uh
i don't i don't want to get into too
much but there's like a been a weird
thing where like we're just getting
we've been like likes have been just
going away or whatever but uh if you do
like the show leave us a like comment
below
because we appreciate it when you uh
support the show and
uh go to teamcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a great uh
exclusive members-only segment coming up
after we're gonna be talking about a
convention of states
right that's what we're gonna talk about
we already thought about we got we got
to do it because you're you know
article five conversation convention of
states can make uh can makes
can make the disillusion of the united
states legal if necessary
to avoid war to avoid a death toll
timcast.com we'll be talking about that
around 11 or so it should be up but
let's read some super chats we got roddy
the rotsky says hey tim
we know your guest on friday was a ccp
mouthpiece what with his being a
contributor on their state news
i wanted to at least shout out your work
you've done studying china
and not just letting him see you
propaganda well um
you know i always enjoy having people of
different opinions and i certainly
had my arguments with what he was saying
i think i did like a four-minute rant
where i was like here's what china is
doing here's why it's bad
here's what's gonna happen to us we're
losing our rights billionaires are
becoming deferential to china
then they're lobbying they're putting
money into lobbying with our own
politicians that we vote against our
rights
i think those conversations are
important whether or not they're perfect
we're gonna have a lot of people come in
the show probably are gonna have bad
opinions so
yeah it is what it is you've had vosh
yeah we had vasha and destiny
and i i respect them for doing it but
destiny's opinions aren't nearly as bad
as vosh i think destiny's got
totally respectable opinions yeah yeah
yeah destiny was actually fairly smart
um
i i just disagree i should say destiny
was smart i don't mean to be
disrespectful i mean
he has uh interesting arguments i think
he was just lacking information a lot of
things
and there's a lot of people on the left
who simply we just we know different
things
which shapes our opinions and then we
get in arguments and we're like wait a
minute and then there's like a clash and
then we're adamant on our stuff so
destiny i
i thought was actually great because he
defended caltrans yeah
you know he was he like if he can see it
he's honest and he assessed it i respect
that
i think you know some people have
brought up that vosh said that lying to
to
get your way sometimes is acceptable and
i mean bosh is just bad
hey look i'm willing to have you know
whoever so i mean i mean if
it's there's nothing wrong with like
four hours there's nothing wrong with
having you know
people with bad opinions on it makes for
good youtube videos you know
oh yeah all right let's see we got here
kayla rayne says tim do you think this
will ever actually stop though
the media are like charles manson not me
i just told them to so this is becoming
the norm
yup yeah i don't even understand what
she was saying
uh the media is going to keep putting
out these lies and framing things
properly and then
acting like they had nothing to do with
it like when they say uh uh
you know that the prosecution is winning
yeah dude if you've been watching this
trial
you're probably laughing at how how
clownishly bad the prosecution is
yeah and it's crazy how slate actually
says is the
is the defense floundering i was i was i
was listening or i was in an exchange
today with a
with a young lady that was sure that uh
chauvin you know was was guilty guilty
and blah blah i'm like
the the prosecution hasn't even rested
and the defense hasn't even presented
their case yet
how can you be sure and she was just
adamant that he was
and i'm like let me lay it out
we've only heard from the prosecution so
far they've had about one or two good
days
and a good day doesn't mean a great day
or slam dunk day even within one of
these good days the defense still got a
major slam dunk
when the medical examiner said she was
asked if you saw
george floyd in his apartment you know
he was dead and you came
in how would you would you ass how would
you assess this is a drug overdose
what if he didn't have drugs in the
system heart failure
reasonable doubt what these what people
don't understand is
the burden is on the state yeah so if
they're looking at it like she's
canadian
you know all right oh right right there
if they're looking at this like
the state doesn't need to prove he was
guilty they just need to suggest it
no no no no they got to prove being a
reasonable doubt so the defense was very
effective at raising reasonable doubt in
almost every single circumstance
even getting one of the paid expert
witnesses to admit
derek chovin used less force than
authorized
which intent is out the window that's
two and three are gone murder two and
three are gone
because if he was authorized he was a
taser and he didn't because he wanted to
use lesser force
then murder two requires the intent to
murder murder three requires the intent
to cause harm which results in death
but he chose to use less force yeah how
are you gonna get him on that
manslaughter maybe but i still don't
think so
i'm not i'm an expert legal insurrection
disagrees they say
he might get manslaughter at this point
we'll see i i'm not getting how news
media can write articles like
did tim poole just commit murder by
slamming a brick into a guy's head
and that can be the title of the article
and of course in the article like no
but that the title of the article did
did this person commit
this heinous crime it'll be like while
tim poole was nowhere near the man and
never had a brick and has nothing to do
with this story we're still questioning
whether or not his actions could have
evolved
i mean just because it's a question mark
and that the word did doesn't mean that
you're not accusing
like at some point you can't just say
something illegal in a video game speech
bravo apparently you're gonna ask me in
a video
in a video and ask a question that's the
look look the inner video game thing
isn't real
like like these these leftists you've
seen have you seen you've seen i've seen
a song do it yeah
in in minecraft dude
it won't work video game yeah they don't
they don't understand like
when you when you so that so for those
understand they'll say something like
we should you know commit ax crime in a
video game
no no no no that's not how things work
you
the the question is whether or not you
intended to incite to violence not
what you said so there's a there's a bit
from the widest kids you know
where he explains he's like my lawyers
told me that i can't say and then he
says something about the president
i also i'm told i can't tell you to come
at this point at 7 p.m
and bring with you these things and like
he goes through this the point is when
you watch that
you know it's a comedy show and he's
joking and he's not actually intending
to incite anything
when you watch a political commentator
who's routinely said
very explicit you know things and then
he says
we should all go and do x yeah
in a video game in a video game it's
like dude you think a judge is going to
be like oh
can you see that in minecraft should we
all go commit x crime on tuesday at 4 pm
are you allowed to say stuff like that
no it depends on whether you're
intending to actually incite
so try like these people don't get this
i love this when i was when i was
younger they'd be like
we're we're going to have a kegger it's
it's uh you know it's
the beer is free we can't sell beer
that's illegal so you can but the cup
costs 20
and i'm like that's called solicitation
and the cops still arrest you
do you think the cops are dumb they're
like rats they got us
they're selling cups not beer no they're
like you're selling beer shut up
i love there's this movie with i can't
remember what it is there there
there is a there used to be a store in
western massachusetts
that was an adult video store
and for some reason about zoning or
something like that they couldn't be
just an adult video store so they
literally were the cup store and they
had
51 percent of the store was styrofoam
cups
because it was the cheapest thing and
the rest was an adult was adult video i
mean obviously this is this is back
you know probably 15 20 years maybe like
20 years at least it's over 10 years ago
because i haven't lived in massachusetts
in
over a decade but they used to have
there was one and it was uh
on riverdale road in western in west
springfield massachusetts
there's a movie where some dude is
trying to buy drugs and the guy goes are
you a cop cause you got to tell me if
you are and he goes
i'm not a cop dude and he's like you got
to tell me i was such a trap he's like
dude i'm not a cop news
all right all right let's you know i'll
sell you and then the guy goes pull that
as bad you're under arrest
you said you weren't a cop and he's like
why would i tell you i was would you do
what undercover means
but people just actually believe that
that lie if the cop doesn't tell you to
treatment
dude you can't go on a stream say you
want to commit a crime then at in a
video game
if they want to prosecute for it they
will they probably don't because they
don't take it seriously
yeah all right we got i i'll fight you
naked
says the most dangerous are not bad
people doing evil things
beware of demons who think themselves
angels embrace the romantic honor in
fighting for a hopeless cause
i'll fight you naked says that huh
that's right that's right that's right
so yeah joey martinez says hell yeah
phil
that's right hell yeah let's see what is
this
uh dw says holy crap tim cast irl has
visible john cena on their show
is that your title i don't know
apparently that was like
hugh jackman yeah hugh jackman
all right let's see captain says tim any
chance you will accept payment on your
website with something other than paypal
they are very anti-gun my friends the
new website
actually has uh uh i don't know if it's
live yet because we just got it up we're
still
you know fixing dimensions it's you know
you do it as you go but we're gonna have
stripe
and uh uh i like stripe i actually
stripe's really good
you can send tim one bitcoin no no we
can't do that
oh you can't you can't yeah like we have
a donation thing but we can't take it
for memberships
really yeah too bad it's really
complicated you could send me
one bitcoin well so we're we're gonna
have stripe i don't know if it's live
yet
but you'll be able to sign up and not
use paypal
granted most people need to realize
stripe and paypal have everything paypal
has the majority and stripes a little
bit
but uh i'm actually i'm fairly impressed
with stripe to be completely honest
paypal own stripe
i don't think so let me look that up but
uh
we we signed up because a lot of people
have said they weren't big fans of
paypal so we're like well we
will add that and i i'm impressed with
the with the the mechanics
of the of stripe all right let's see we
got here
standing while pooping says phil what
the hell happened to ollie herbert
did his druggie wife kill him uh
i don't know that i can say that um
i can say that 44 year old men
that have no history of drug use and no
history of health issues don't just die
they don't interesting so uh confirmed
stripe is not owned by paypal okay
it's the most valuable company in
silicon valley at 95 billion
stripe is yeah owned by patrick and john
collison
wow that's awesome it's the most
valuable yeah that's what according to
this google search wow they've got great
functionality i'll say that
i would like more diversity in terms of
you know competition and everything but
i'm glad there's more than just paypal
the most valuable private company in
silicon valley oh so it's not hasn't
gone public yet
gavin campbell says she shed a taser
three times she might have had her gun
drawn saying someone tased so not to
pull the trigger
there's more than one angle also for a
super chat that's actually a good point
yep
she might have been saying taser taser
taser because she wanted them to tase
and then when he was reaching she shot
him and said holy ass i just shot him
and it may have not been an accident it
may have been nobody was doing anything
and the guy was wanted on a gun charge
it's tragic it's tragedy man this dude i
i hate to hear that somebody lost their
life simply because they wanted to have
a gun
which they're allowed to do constitution
said so we became a nation
that started crapping all over the
constitution minnesota this is what they
do
and now young man's dead and i'll tell
you this they're going to blame the cops
okay
peop some people are more responsible
than others but if you're looking for
the guilty party for the people in this
blue state you need to only look in the
mirror
you vote for these laws that criminalize
the right to bear arms
and there are so many young black men in
these cities in places like minneapolis
and chicago
who are being locked up and having their
lives ruined because they want to own a
gun and the constitution says they can
there's there's so much hazard that goes
along with
circumventing the second amendment um
and it's part of the reason why
it's part of the reason why people like
joe biden says things like no
amendment is absolute well you know i
think that
we're pretty absolute about slavery like
that is pretty
absolutely out of the question women's
right to vote yeah women's right to vote
i'm pretty sure we're
absolute about that and i'm confident
that most people are pretty
absolute about the fourth amendment when
the police are at their house
when they come to your house and say
that i want to come in without a warrant
or when they pull you over and say i'm
going to take your money
without any kind of warrant or anything
like that you'll be pretty absolute
about the fourth amendment too
pete the hazard about circumventing
amendments
is it makes it acceptable to circumvent
other amendments people need to
understand
you live the fourth amendment probably
more than any other amendment yeah this
is true
when when the cops if we didn't have the
fourth amendment
cops would randomly break into your home
randomly
they'd come into your neighborhood and
they'd they just they kick the door and
be like sit down and shut up we're
looking for somebody and we're checking
your house
we have the fourth amendment which means
they have to get a warrant signed by a
judge
so typically they'll knock on your door
and you can say come back with a warrant
and then they'll go you know they might
say something like oh it'll be a lot
easier and
i said what i said come back with a
warrant you know you can be polite about
it look no disrespect
just please come back with a warrant any
any kind of anything that circumvents
existing amendments makes it more likely
that they will circumvent
other amendments so let me ask you
something actually
red flag laws we we mostly view them as
very bad ideas
right what if there was no gun law
except red flag law so i'll put it this
way we we say that
unreasonable search and seizure is not
allowed to the fourth but the cops can
get a signed statement from a judge
allowing them to enter your home
what if there were no laws infringing
gun rights but they could get a signed
statement from a judge
taking your gun temporarily for a health
check or something if it's a signed
statement from a judge
i i haven't put a lot of thought to this
so
i could probably be swayed either way
because i haven't
honestly sat down and really mulled over
the the ramifications so
it's possible that i'm speaking and and
my opinion would change
but if the if there is a judge that
signs
the warrant that says that that they're
going to do that i
think that might be okay that's how red
flag laws work do they have there has to
be a judge signing
the judge signs off on yeah my
understanding is maybe they're different
my understanding is red flag laws is
they'll go to the judge and say here's
why we believe this to be true this
person's a threat
the judge will say okay then you can
temporarily i don't like it because some
states will have
legal medical marijuana or legal
recreational marijuana and the federal
government's like it's a it's a
schedule one narcotic uh i'm signing the
warrant don't take his guns not only
that
you you know you can one of the big
things about red red flags laws that are
bad is the
is the possibility of abuse your family
member you're getting to a fight with
your girlfriend or your ex-wife or
calls the cops and says oh they did this
and blah blah blah so the cops come and
take your property and so i actually
just today heard the story of a guy who
uh
left a bad review for his doctor and
called his doctor angry about his pain
not being managed after his surgery his
doctor
went to the judge and made it happen his
guns got taken away yeah
i mean the they're they're just so
dangerous
because especially with into in society
today where who's so quick to call the
police on your
on neighbors and stuff you're the the
less
the lower trust the society is the more
necessary the state becomes and as
communities get bigger
and have and you have less interaction
with people
on a personal level the less trust you
will have in your communities and so
that means that you will end up with the
police being called
more frequently i i don't know
i i don't know that i have a good answer
for your question i was just it's just a
thought because the fourth and i meant
we're like okay well if the judge says
so it's okay right
yeah well people are like red flag laws
nah so yeah i don't know
so we got a good super chat here from
kurt crystal he says tim i searched
riots on
bing and the top result was minneapolis
and and then kenosha somehow after that
definitions and encyclopedia listings
all right google's out we're all going
bing that's microsoft bing bing
bing it is i'm kidding goes butter if
there's a search engine that uh
produce it when you search riot that
produces paramore's record i will
start using that search engine that's a
great record i love paramore yeah you
like
i thought ryan was pretty good i think
it's a great record what do you think
about paramore lately
uh i'm not i've been listening to their
stuff recently i think hey i mean haley
the the reason that i found paramore is
i heard haley doing an acoustic thing
and i was just
blown away by your scene she's just
phenomenal phenomenal absolutely great
musician
so yeah yeah i was a big fan of paramore
for a while the newer stuff is more
is different but you know i saw an ad
haley was doing ads on facebook to do
like mental health sessions with people
and i was like oh you know i never
really listened to paramore and i
started listening to their stuff
she's phenomenal yeah she's just had
great music back
back in the day but like i guess the
style changed for a variety of reasons
people grow up they were kind of like
ska
almost what was it like pop punk you
think to me
yeah pop it was very warped tour right
right yeah
when i hear paramore i think of warp
tour you know i think of
i mean it's still heavier than green day
right
and that's like i it's like no doubt if
you were weighted down
by chains that then you broke and they
were no the weights were no longer there
it was
better than than green day yeah well
green day stuff was always like
like more bubbly at least paramore had
some like serious topics that were kind
of like
sometimes dark yeah green day was very
family friendly happy
and you know it was never even i guess i
guess i guess the lack of breakfast
is darker than you know whatever
all right let's read more before we get
feeling trouble for making fun of people
or something
oh i'm good at that myself all right
let's see 101
dumar says last time phil was in studio
you didn't know his music and who he was
you have an absolute star in studio how
did you not know two weeks among many
other great songs he has explain
yourself
i i'll be completely honest i of course
know who phil is
but i've never been a big metal fan or
you know i don't know i don't know every
single person in the world
genres are are a funny thing i think
that that
someone can be very well known in in one
genre
and be if they if you know people don't
pay attention to that genre
they're you know it's just another face
in the crowd and that makes sense to me
because there are tons of
of musicians out there that are huge in
in
genres that i don't listen to that i'm
just like eh you know i mean who
who knows i i know who the guys in air
supply are but not everybody knows who
air supply is you know yeah
yeah so like i mean i've i've met
throughout my career tons of people and
i'm
oh man i have one funny story i'm not
gonna name the actress but like i was at
a bar
back when i worked at vice and my friend
introduced me to this very famous
actress
who i didn't know and i was like have
you been in anything i would have seen
and she like named some movies and i was
like i hated that movie
oh wow apparently she's like one of the
biggest celebrities and i'm like
you know look man my buddy i was like i
didn't mean to
say and she was like well i hate vice
and i'm like all right i shouldn't have
said
touche i wasn't thinking it was a rude
comment and she's actually in a bunch of
really amazing movies i'm a big fan of
but
she's great and uh after the show i want
to know who this is
oh yeah yeah for sure i just yeah i
i've had my share of meeting people who
are oh paw
you know i don't know i treat everybody
basically the same i guess
i got invited to a bunch of like like
several times now like hollywood
celebrity parties
with like famous mainstream tv show
people and movie people
and i'm like legit thanks for the offer
i just got to work man so like respect
it's not it's not really my scene it's
not really my thing i've always
that's why i was talking about people
all the people doing selfies and like
trying to be like mainstream tribal i'm
like i don't care about that dude
let me go in the woods and like you know
go to a shooting range or something in
my own business i feel that there's a
lot of
there's a lot of schmoozing that
is supposed to go on in the
entertainment industry
that myself and people in my band
have been very very bad at there's a lot
of bands that get
a lot more attention than you then their
numbers
would think they have dessert they
deserve because they're
you know friendly with people in the
media or friendly with people in
in the business side of it no one in our
band lives in l.a
well our guitar player lives in la now
but uh
for the vast majority of our career we
were new englanders didn't hang out in
new york city
we weren't involved in the
scene or the business side of it any
further than we had to be
and uh and i think that that
that possibly has been something that
has that that would have
if we were more schmoozy we would have
been able to
do even more than we've done and i don't
want to downplay what we've done i mean
not a lot of bands get to be around for
20 years and
and we're super fortunate um but i but
it does
you know there is truth in the idea that
you know
networking matters and stuff yeah
definitely man
all right this is great george hodges
says tim if you're looking for black
lives matter riots on google you
probably have to type in peaceful
protest
haha and you call yourself an
investigative reporter
okay that's fair i'm gonna look up
protests i bet he's right
joss uh jos mosque says stephen
crowder's crew found an aggravated
robbery charge for the young gentleman
that got shot by the cops just something
to kind of check out
all right you know legit uh and that's
why i think it's a different
circumstance so this woman was
fearful i mean look the guy had a gun
charge and she was worried he had a
weapon i get that
i'm just like i'd like to see people
have the right to keep and bear arms
do you know what i mean that guy is
totally right if you type protests in
google
dante right shooting minnesota sparks
protests
protests gather outside amazing
no way it should have been so obvious to
me i dropped the ball on that one
boo wow framing man and that was uh
george hodges nailed it
i shouldn't i should have you know but
it's like a meme
i didn't think to actually type in
peaceful protests it's right there and
you just
you see through it you type in peaceful
protest you're going to get minnesota
you type in people just type protest oh
okay that's fine
funny brilliance all right let's see
come and take them says tim myself and
two others just finished
a feature-length movie with oscar emmy
and grammy winners and
nominees we'll commit 10 10k to your
production
and would like to help please advise on
how to discuss discreetly
um man that's always tough i suppose we
need to set up an email for this but we
have spin the ufo at gmail
are you able to i'll get that look for
that and then cool yeah we want to i
want to do short films i'm going to do
uh i want to do feature lengths man
granted it'll be relatively low budget
because you know you know you know bums
me out man i was talking about this
thing on one of my videos today
a lot of these people on substance for
instance make a million bucks
from writing their articles and they get
like 10 000 people to pay 10 bucks
and i'm like man why aren't these people
doing
more like you know glenn greenwald
leaves the intercept
he made the intercept start start again
dude make a new site
use those resources to bring more people
on expand make sure
more good journalists are getting able
to do that job
well i know i'll do it but if i had like
some of the money of these big big
celebrity dudes and these massive
podcasts
you know you mentioned earlier how
i think that the the fact of the matter
is part of the the limitation
is that quality people to work with are
not as they're not as as
you don't come across them as frequently
as you would like to think i suppose
you know it's like if you've got a lot
of money to invest that's one thing but
you need someone reliable and
creative and you know with a good work
ethic
that you can invest in yeah and as it's
probably harder to come across than
than than we we wish that it was i found
you know
the best people to work with are the
people that truly believe in it
and they don't want the money i mean
they'll take the money and i force them
to take the money but
you just gotta speak to the soul like
armbar forcing yeah i'll put it behind
their back and press until they cry yeah
usually all right let's read some more
of these megan davis says my guy and i
love your show and a couple weeks ago we
saw jp sears love at vassani
i told him that i heard on a previous
cast you discussing his coming on the
show he said he would
hope he reaches out keep up the good
work i hope he doesn't would love to
have jp series
however people who host shows it's like
you know they've got a full-time job
they're hosting in their own show
and it's harder when you have like a
daily schedule or weekly schedule to
like stop your production for someone
else's show
but uh jp sears is always invited and uh
we there's a lot of there's a lot of
people who do their own shows we'd love
to have on
but i respect it man you know it's like
hey come stop doing your show do mine
instead
that's hard come out for a sunday jp
and uh hang out at the house and then
let's do a show monday that's a good
idea i like that yeah
all right here we go tag and [ __ ] was
here says did you see that jason
whitlock got locked for a tweet
criticizing the blm co-founder for
buying those houses
says that he's in twitter jail because
he won't delete it mad respect
blm stands for by large mansion buy
large mansions yeah
she bought one large mansion she says
three other reasons we didn't even talk
about that
the the co the founder of black lives
matter well i don't know the trade
marxist a founder bought four houses
yeah totaling like two million dollars
good for her yeah good for her it proves
they're not marxist checkmate bigots
yeah
there you go they can claim to be on
their own next thing you know she's
gonna airbnb
and then be a landlord too
there's a really funny article i gotta
admit where it's like they're they're
talking about this trend of tick tockers
talking about they're calling it like
rent hacking where they're like
here's how you can live for free and
it's a woman she's like i bought a
building
down payment five percent and then i
rented out the first second floor
and now i don't pay rent it's like
you're a landlord okay
that's nice that's rent hacking that's
one of the that's actually one of the
one of the uh most common ways for
people to become
if not wealthy to become you know to
save for their retirement stuff
buy a property and you have people rent
it and
they pay your mortgage and then you get
the
you're not paying the the principal
and you're also getting the equity in
the home it's like
that's how you can build a business or
at least
make money to save for your retirement
so that way you're not relying on the
you know two thousand dollar check from
social security or whatever i'll admit i
think the system is
system is trash what system the system
we have in place in general right
there's people i remember that when i
was buying my first house
it was very difficult and they were like
oh your credit history or your bank
account or whatever
and i'm like my rent costs more than the
mortgage dude
like i can pay if i can pay for this and
they're like well we don't think so
that's the stupidest thing ever yeah
so there are people who can easily
afford a 2k mortgage right
and they're being told you can't have
this loan even though your rent is 22.50
in new york city
that's stupid yeah give them a loan you
know and the thing
i mean that's that's that speaks to the
way that our our credit system
works and the fact that you know the
credit system doesn't just depend on if
you pay your bills on time
every month it really does depend on if
they're making money off of you so
you'll you're it helps your credit to
have some money
that stays on a credit card you'll get
more points if they're actually
that that money that's on the credit
card the bank is making uh
you know making a profit off of the
internet off the interest they charge
you
so it's literally extorting you for
you're literally paying
to have a good credit history it's not
just about
if you're paying your bills on time and
stuff so credit system is wack it is it
really is so
you know it really is so all right chris
rose 1986 says i live in georgia and no
one is wearing masks
they mask the kids they make the kids
wear masks going to school and like
walmart
government buildings the government
always f things up and they will f
up the chip so that is a hard pass
and then we got a big rig says what
happens if you need an mri while having
these microchips oops ooh
am i right we'll rip it out of your
flesh right out yep
all right let's see we got here lance a
says long time follower
i discovered a new crypto called elon
gate
elongate that doesn't sound right uh
let's see
a d5 charity token that has donated 825k
within a week
it's partnering with elon musk brother
soon too
going to be the best real world crypto
result growing fast check it out tim
cast crew love you guys
shill your coin homie well elon steal
your coins
elon tweeted if there's ever a scandal
about me i hope it's called elon gate
uh and then i tweeted tax the rich and
give all the money to elon i still love
him
that's hilarious give me give it all oh
what's this
midnight smoker says jimmy dore did an
interview on the aoc california highway
patrol incident a few days ago
interesting jimmy's legit i tweeted that
props
for jimmy i tweeted out that link to the
uh the the guy that was so it was legit
like yeah i criticized him
yeah yeah left wing podcaster criticizer
who was it uh i don't know his i don't
recognize his name right now
she made like like comments about her
support of palestine i think
yeah cops at his door wow yeah straight
up
no joke aoc is a bad person
yes i called her she's donald trump just
with
boobies she's worse than trump she's
yeah i think she's worse i think trump
actually had
some convictions i don't think she does
yeah maybe i think trump
she might have until she made a
six-figure you know she got to
washington and was making six figures
yeah yeah when it was like listen you
play ball or you you're out
she went okay i'll play ball i'd rather
look at her than trump though i mean
yeah that's fair
i don't know man trump those those
burgeoning muscles
that glorious
[Laughter]
well it's funny because the left would
draw trump as this like hunched over
morbidly obese with tiny hands yeah and
ben garrison's hymns upright six foot
you know whatever it's super tall
with the left draws trump it's
essentially oswald copperpot from
that from batman but without the pointy
nose and with a blonde with a blonde
blonde hair that's that's the way the
left sees donald trump pretty much yeah
oswald copper pie cobble pot cobble pot
cobble pie
penguin yeah yeah all right let's see
edge of the south says sometimes it's
best to keep computers completely
offline
especially ones that contain sensitive
info or control processes that could
cause death or bodily harm have hacked
if the computer is is your brain you
definitely should keep it offline
got an air gap that brain i mean fair
enough but
no what if you get what if you get a a
brain virus
as in a computer virus in your brain
yeah well again
i'm i'm only thinking about an inter
thinking about it as a
for an interface so it's not like it's
it's actually going into your brain
to like put data in it yeah you know
it's literally it's just the the
as if i understand the concept correctly
they would simply use the electrodes
so that way output only basically so
yeah so that way you can you know so
it's not like i'm like
i'm not seeing the information on my eye
it would just literally be i would be
able to look at my screen or my phone
and output it i guess you could hack the
output if
so when you think go left it goes right
that might that might happen why would
it go the other direction if someone
wanted like a specific outcome well then
it's just the most annoying
part it's just this irritating thing
yeah that would
and then and if and then it's like i
suppose like if they did do that you're
just like
son of a [ __ ] and you gotta just think
opposite
yeah or like and no matter what you
think it spells out the same thing over
and over again
it's like bad auto autocorrect all right
let's see sean
sean casey fpv says first time super
chat i've been watching daily for the
pat for the last six months love your
work i will sub
an exclusive membership if you and phil
hold a quick jam session in your
exclusive hour
we don't do a full exclusive hour but if
you ever want to jam man we should you
know
sounds like fun we could jam you know
great i mean you're the professional
career musician so you probably got
constrained
i mean i i preferred to rehearse before
performing so it'd be something that
we'd have to do you know come down and
hang out and and
do but wow you should do it man i don't
know if you guys ever want to come and
jam where we want to do friday night
jams again
be sick yeah we're we're coming up with
a plan so that
now that it's nicer out we're going to
camera up the the skatepark outside
so that we can actually have like a
stage set up yeah and then we can be
like friday night like all right we're
switching to the garage cam boom hit the
button and then sick
in the garage you know all right let's
see joshua
rusinski fellow former u.s marine here
semper fi phil tim i've been following
you for over a year now you guys put
together great content most importantly
happy anniversary to my my amazing
girlfriend angie love you
josh that was awesome dad teaches and
words to my son says can smeagle say
their pronouns one's self wants it you
haven't
you have a very good schmiegel yeah it's
a it's it's a really good idea to be
honest man
i hear like everyone always says i do a
good impersonation of no matter who i'm
doing it over
that one that one is is good who was it
was it who was like
man you're you're michael moore was so
good yeah i was like on balance
i don't even remember how i did the i
was doing michael moore i was
i was actually just quoting michael
moore and then turned it into an
baby yeah somebody who's sitting here
yeah
yeah i can do some eagles yeah you're
like you're michael moore is awesome
i don't even remember how i did you
gotta do a freedom tunes one you gotta
do michael moore
or uh yeah if i actually practiced yeah
i could probably on call like very
easily do a lot of impersonations
but usually it's like when i'm in the
flow and talking and then i'm like i
want to reference something i'll do it
like i was reading that when they
mentioned smeagle i kind of just like
yeah
it came out i guess i think smigo's
actually really easy it's like one of
the easiest impersonations
impersonations i can almost do it yeah
yeah just talk like those and then you
gotta add a little bit like stitch
from lilo and stitch it's weird i don't
know just kind of close your throat
while you're talking
i didn't know i don't recall stitch
talking but i mean i think i've seen
wheeling what are you just like no he
talked yeah a little bit yeah
sound like he sounded like going kevin
pilgrim says so sick you got phil on
taking me right back to middle school
love phil and all that remains
sick bro come on
jay rich says tonight's topics are
display of a left's march to madness
they turn up the heat on covid race
gender etc what you laugh about today
becomes policy tomorrow
where do you all draw the line or will
you stay in the pot until you're slowly
cooked
uh we're in the middle of nowhere like
in the mountains
i mean i my house in new hampshire is is
in the you know it's back in the woods
i've got 48 acres of
property in my house is in the back of
the lot it's not on the road you don't
accidentally onto my property
and i got an apartment in texas that
i've been staying in that i'll be there
for a while
in case of article 5. i will draw the
line with pronouns
if you ask me to call you a pronoun i
might and that's up to me
because i have the right to free speech
that's a good point
if sd says semper fi phil tim when when
will we start having barbecues and
hangouts at the gorilla ranch aka
aka your house yes well we're calling it
cast castle
passively but maybe gorilla ranch is
better right
the gorilla what has alex jones done to
my house
alex jones has done nothing wrong isn't
it scary
isn't it scary how a lot of the things
that alex jones we thought were
silly crazy alex jones rants are like
wait a minute why
why why are you making alex jones
correct
stop doing that that's making me making
me feel uncomfortable
when joe rogan was like dude we owe that
guy an apology
he's talking about the epstein's stuff
his dad is like super secret program
guys so he would
he grew up at the kitchen table hearing
like you know navy
secrets and stuff he i mean of course
they're going to make them stop
making alex jones right yes please world
all right we'll do a couple more because
we we went a little bit over
but uh we have eraserhead says
phil please please please introduce tim
to andrew
wilco i've listened to your interviews
on the wilcow welcome majority for years
and i would love to hear tim have a
conversation with him
love you based beanie bros i'm not
familiar with who that
uh andrew does a uh show on uh xm
patriot he's a friend um and he's a
he's a conservative um
libertarian-minded conservative
he's definitely more conservative than
i am i mean i'm very very libertarian
um i'm open borders libertarian
generally if we can end the
if we can end the welfare state then i
would i would be down with open borders
okay um and andrew's more conservative
than i am but uh
yeah he's a great guy he's really really
nice uh we get along he's into metal he
comes out to shows and we play at a
starling ballroom and stuff like that
that's so cool he's a good dude
zeke weiss says phil my sister ray used
to work merch for you guys
she was devastated when she found out
about ali's death she saw him and the
rest of you as good friends she is doing
fine hope the same for the band
i hope she's doing well and
all right we were all pretty devastated
when we found out about ollie so
so we'll just do uh let's do one more
here matthew conley says sorry phil i'm
more of a disturbed guy with music
even though they're lead singer as
libertarian you're the one spreading
their message outside their music
that's right i i mean it's probably not
exactly a great idea because
people that strongly disagree tend to
have a
strong reaction and the media the metal
media is
like the rest of the media there oh yeah
very very very the the some of the most
influential blogs are are dudes with
sickles and hammers and their names
metal that seems so weird to me it is
weird
but uh yeah so it
i take a lot of heat on in the metal
blogs because of it
because of my you know i am a principled
libertarian that
generally a principled libertarian that
it is not afraid to say look
people should be free the government's
too big dropping bombs on poor people in
other countries is bad
and for some reason i thought that these
wouldn't be all that controversial of
takes but apparently they are you know
it's weird weird times man it is and
don't forget to add second amendment
yeah you know i mean mulan levy you know
right on my arm so
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for hanging out if you haven't already
give us a give us a good like
smash that like button subscribe because
i think we're on the verge of breaking
one million subscribers and with your
help we will accomplish that so
love y'all and seriously thanks for for
for being on this journey
and helping us grow to the point we are
go to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a members only exclusive
episode coming up
maybe a little bit after 11 actually
gone a little bit over but uh we'll be
talking about some stuff about
article five convention of states what
that means and i think it might
it'll get interesting it'll get very
interesting so again subscribe hit the
notification bell hit that like button
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast my other youtube
channels are youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews
this show is live monday through friday
at 8 pm so leave us a good review if
you're listening on itunes or spotify
because that really really or any
podcast platform it really does help and
uh
phil you want to shout anything out yeah
um i am phil that remains on uh
twitter on twitch i stream monday
tuesday thursday friday
uh sing all the remains songs um
if you want to support you can support
me on patreon patreon.com philip remains
uh shout out to my friends at brownells
if you guys are looking for firearms
accessories and stuff check out my
affiliate link brownells at brownells um
yeah if you want to find me on the
internet mines phil that remains uh
basically anywhere phil that remains
that's me
yeah you guys can follow me in
crossland.net at ian crossland on pretty
much every social media platform that
there is and phil
awesome as always cheers and as for me i
am sour patch lids on twitter
and today i received the greatest news
of my life and that is that
in just a short while i will have more
followers than sour patch
kids has on twitter i know i was really
excited so please go and follow me at
sour sourpatchlids on twitter
we will see you all over at timcast.com
with an exclusive
members only segment with phil thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all there
bye guys
you